Okay Leute, irgendwer von euch, oder um genau zu
3 Leute von euch sind vom Rechner eingeschlafen oder haben den Tab noch auf, weil ich habe
instant beim ersten Refresh 4 Zuschauer, einer davon ist meine Vorschau, aber die anderen
drei bin ich nicht. Also irgendjemand wundert sich gerade, warum bei ihm im Hintergrund
der Max wieder labert, weil er den Tab vergessen hat oder er ist eingeschlafen, ich wecke ihn
jetzt auf oder nicht. 1 von beiden. 1,2,5,2,5 wer hat 2,5,2,5? Twitch Prime, Dankeschön,
exellent Subscription. Oder Patrick ist gar nicht mehr Subscribed, was ist denn da los?
Ich glaube ich bin mal so frei, weißt du was? Du hast so viele Sachen schon gegiftet und
Zeug verschenkt und alles. Äh, ich kann dir... und eigentlich wollte ich dir gerade ein Abo
giften, aber es geht gerade nicht. Warum geht das nicht? Ah doch, jetzt. Twitch hat rumgespackt,
exellent. Das Flaschen der Steckdose hat nicht funktioniert, weil es die falsche CPU ist
die drin war. Ich habe das Ding aufgeschraubt und habe reingeschaut, es war eine MediaTek
CPU, kein ESP866. Was halt echt fail ist, weil die Steckdosenleistung exakt, also sogar
die Knopfanordnung exakt so aus, wie auf der Steckdosenleistung im ESP866. Also wirklich
exakt genauso. Ja Patrick, schön, dass du so lange am Start bist. Exellent. 15 Monate
ersetzt am Start. Ne ne, es ist was ganz anderes drauf. Es ist eine MediaTek drauf. Es ist irgendeine
MediaTek CPU drauf. Es ist was ganz anderes, es ist sehr merkwürdig, weil ich dachte eigentlich
die Hersteller bauen den Kram gar nicht selber, sondern kaufen das von irgendeinem Trittanbieter,
weil das wäre auch die Begründung dafür, warum so viele Hersteller exakt gleich Steckdosenleiste
verkaufen. Diese Steckdosenleiste gibt es tausendfach auf Amazon. Ja tausendfach und
die hat halt ein MediaTek kein ESP866. Findet ihr den Witz auch so painstchampig? Eigentlich
sehr übelst lustig, aber ich hab den schon so oft gebracht und gelesen, dass er nicht
verlustig ist. Ja, das ist MediaTek Testorsion, das hat mich auch gewundert. Gerade die CooCommodates
aus China bauen eigentlich nur ESP866 eingefüllt. So, machen wir jetzt mal diesen huge joke
weg und gehen hier mal zurück. Ups, ich mach mal kurz zu hier den ganzen Kram und ich mach
mal ein Chatfenster auf, falls ich wieder nicht zurückscrollen kann, das wieder rumspackt.
Ist halt auch wahr, ja. Ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie gerne ich mit Python oder irgendeiner
ordentlichen Programmiersprache, ich zeig euch mal was, das ganze programmieren würde
für den Controller und nicht mit C++. MicroPython ist in dem Fall keine Alternative leider.
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt, aber damit kommste gerade was knappe Ressourcen und SSL Libraries
angeht leider nicht so sonderlich weit. So, ich zeig euch mal was, was ich gefunden hab.
Der SiriusMax fragt, du meintest mal, du hast Netboot XYZ über Docker laufen. Ich habe
das gerade mal probiert, komme auch ins Boot-Menü, aber sobald ich eine Distro auspille,
bekomme ich Network Unreachable. Ich habe in Docker Compose Network Mode noch auf Host
gestellt. Hast du sonst noch was anderes konfiguriert? Nee. Wenn du das Boot-Menü bekommst,
dann liegt das der nächste Schritt aber nicht mehr an dem Netboot XYZ, sondern an deiner
DHCP-Config vermute ich mal. Machst du das, mit was willst du denn booten? BIOS EFI? Also
ich hab diesen Container hier. Docker Hub, den da. Da kann man eigentlich rein, was den
Container angeht, nicht viel falsch machen, starten und man kann PXE booten. Kannst dir
gerade nochmal, wo wir gerade bei sind, zeigen. Wenn man PXE bootet, sieht das Ganze dann
so aus. Moment. Excellent. Network Boot. Bam. Und dann kriegt man per PXE eine Adresse und
man kriegt dann, wenn er die Netzwerkarte konfiguriert hat, kriegt man auch ein Boot-Menü. Tute-Chat.
Excellent. Aber sowas von. Normalerweise, ich probiere mal, ob es bei mir geht. Vielleicht
sind ja auch diese. Was willst du denn starten Serious Max? Ubuntu? Oder was willst du starten?
Weil das liegt wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil an der Gegenstelle oder an deiner DHCP-Config.
Alles vorbei. Was willst du denn starten? Ist jede Distro? Ok, Live CD ist Libian. Bam.
Keine Ahnung, Cinnamon ist egal. Naja, funktioniert. Ok, das geben wir uns jetzt nicht, weil das
dauert jetzt lang, aber das funktioniert ja. Oh, das geht offenbar so lange, dauert es
gerade. Das hat angetäuscht. Ah, oder auch nicht. Lull. Debated. Ist aber komisch, dass
es bei dir nicht geht. Ich meine, ein DNS brauchst du, einen ordentlichen Gateway brauchst
du, aber das kommt wahrscheinlich alles per DHCP. Die PXE-Settings scheinen ja bei dir
zu stimmen, sonst wird es ja gar nicht soweit kommen. Komm, man hat richtig debated, erst
langsam, dann schnell und man denkt, es ist gleich fertig und zack. Doch, wieder nicht.
Trage mal einen lokalen DNS ein, wobei es eigentlich egal ist. Aber man weiß ja nie.
Ich habe meinen lokalen DNS drin, im DHCP. Jetzt legt der nochmal was runter. Ok, die
Live CD ist ja voll debated, Alter. Ich schalte einfach aus. So, also, was wir heute machen
ist folgendes. By the way, bevor wir richtig anfangen, ich zeige euch mal das. Fällt euch
auf, dass die Uhrzeit falsch ist. Ja, Uhrzeit ist falsch. Die Uhrzeit ist falsch, das ist
uns das letzte Mal schon aufgefallen. Und ich weiß woran es liegt. Wir haben überhaupt
nichts falsch gemacht. Guck mal, also, hier oben setze ich ja die Zeitzone-Infos. So,
und hier unten, by the way, der richtige NTP-Server wäre in dem Fall auch der hier, aber das
ist jetzt erstmal egal. Ich gehe nämlich beide. Der eigentliche Fail ist das hier. Die haben
ihre API geändert. Es reicht jetzt nicht mehr, wenn man config-time macht mit dem NTP-Server
und die Zeitzone-Info setzt. Man muss noch sagen tz-set. So, das war's. Die haben einfach
geändert, wie es funktioniert. Also, das ist alles richtig gemacht. Wenn ich den jetzt
flasche, dann stimmt die Uhrzeit klar. Kurze Frage zwischendrin. Hat jemand einen Vorschlag
für einen Baerborn mit zwei Netzwerkarten? Ich suche gefühlt. Äh, ja, ja, ja, warte
mal, ich muss mal in mich gehen, ich muss mal in mich gehen. Ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm,
ähm, Moment, wie heißt das Ding? Ja, der. Fällst du davon? Das einzig dumme an dem ist,
dass der so einen beschissenen Formfaktor hat. Der hat so einen Formfaktor, der irgendwo
nie so richtig reinpasst. Da braucht man irgendwelche Adapter. Aber das ist eigentlich, wenn du
zwei Netzwerkarten willst und ein bisschen Leistung. Ich meine, das ist jetzt, damit
kannst du jetzt nicht große Sprünge machen. Das ist ein, ähm, hier so ein Low-End. Aber
ich meine, guck mal, es sind zwei Mal 2,5 Gigabits Ports. Das ist schon mal Poggers.
Geht natürlich auch ein Gigabit, ne? Ähm, das ist ein Intel, also das ist so ein Celeron,
Pentium, Pentium Ding. Also das ist jetzt kein, äh, i7 oder sowas, ne? Das ist die,
die Low-End, Low-Energy-Geschichte von Intel. Es ist schneller als den Raspberry Pi, aber
so Riesensprünge kannst du nicht machen. Aber je nachdem, was du machen willst, ist
das hier zum Beispiel ein ganz cooles Board. Es gibt, es gibt bestimmt noch mehr Boards
mit diesem Chipsatz, wo sowas drin ist. Ja, also wenn du was noch kleineres willst, die,
also rein für Netzwerk, gibt's, gibt's diese offiziellen PF Science, äh, PF Sense Boxen.
Und ansonsten müsstest du, müsstest du mal sagen, was du, ach so, ok, äh, Sophos XG
Home, ja gut, das müsste, dafür ist das Ding nicht schlecht, doch, dafür müsste das ziemlich
gut passen. Dafür müsste das ziemlich gut passen. Was kostet der eigentlich realistischerweise
betrachtet in Deutschland? Guckt's euch schon mal an, ne? Offizieller Preis, 119 Dollar,
das Kostakram in Deutschland, 145 Euro. Das ist, das ist schon was, äh. Ich würd mir
den auch nicht in Deutschland kaufen, viel zu teuer. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Boards,
äh, ich hab letztens, genau, ich glaub der war das, der mir letztens noch ins Auge gesprungen
ist, ich glaub das könnte, glaub das war der Nanopie. Allerdings ist der beim Nanopie
das Problem, ne, das war der nicht, das war der nicht, aber diese ganzen Raspberry Pi
Clones ist das Problem, die haben halt richtig schlechtes Support, was, was, äh, Software
und Linux und alles angeht. Das ist auch gerade das, was den Raspberry Pi letztendlich so
gut macht. Also der Raspberry Pi, auch, auch der Vierer, auch der Zero, ist im Prinzip
egal welcher, ja. Die haben zwei große Pluspunkte. Erstens ist, die sind relativ günstig, allerdings
gibt es günstigere, und der riesen Vorteil, der mit Abstand größte Vorteil von, von den
Raspberry Pi's sind, dass, ähm, man die beste Software-Unterstützung, Treiber-Unterstützung,
Linux-Aktualität, sonst was, aller Single-Board-Computer kriegt. Es gibt einfach nichts besseres als
den Raspberry Pi in der Richtung. Es gibt, es gibt auch, es gibt im Hinterhalt 30 Milliarden
Tutorials, es gibt, ähm, zigtausend Custom, Custom Sachen auf GitHub, fertige Anleitungen,
fertige Scripts, fertiges Zeug, äh, fertige, ähm, Header und, und, und fertige, ähm,
wie heißt der Kram, den man oben drauf macht? Diese Extension-Boards, die man oben draufsteckt
und sowas. Total massig, ja. Und man muss ja auch mal sagen, gerade mit dem Pi 4, der
mit, okay, der wird ein bisschen warm. Shields, Shields, genau, das meine ich. Äh, Shields,
meine ich. Und es gibt halt auch richtig praktische Sachen. Also mein persönliches Lieblings-Shield,
weil ich das, äh, gut gebrauchen konnte, ist das Ding. Falls es den noch gibt. Der da.
Das ist für den Raspberry Pi 0. Äh, das geht bestimmt auch auf einen normalen Raspberry
Pi, könnt ihr euch mal vorstellen. Das ist, das ist echt praktisch. Wenn man jetzt nicht,
also mal angenommen, man möchte ein bisschen was, äh, elektronikmäßig machen oder ein
bisschen was heimautomatisierungsmäßig machen, da ist alles drauf, was man so braucht.
Und es ist halt für einen Raspberry Pi. Klar, man kann sich ein eigenes Board zusammenstecken
mit einem ESP32 oder irgendeinem anderen Controller, was man dann komplett selbst programmieren
muss, aber hier hast du halt ein komplettes Linux, wo du per SSH drauf kommst. Oh, es
ist discontinued, ja, das suckt. Das ist richtig gut, das Ding. Du hast, ähm, du hast im Prinzip
das, was dir bei einem Raspberry Pi fehlt. Du hast analog-digital-Converter, bin ich
mir gar nicht sicher. Hat der Raspberry Pi standardmäßig sowas? Nee, ich glaub nicht,
aber du hast, ähm, Relays. Nee, hier ist das Relay. Das sieht man ja auch hier, da ist
es oben drauf. Man hat noch mal extra Anschlüsse für weitere Komponenten, weil die Header-Pins
sind blockiert. Ja, das ist bisher so mein absolutes Lieblings-Shield, weil man damit
richtig viel machen kann. Ach ja, und im Vergleich zum Raspberry Pi sind diese Dinger bis zu
24 Volt hier, die Anschlüsse. Alles. Also, nicht nur, der Raspberry Pi ist ja 5, 5, 3,3?
Äh, 5. Ich glaub, der Raspberry Pi ist komplett 5 Volt, oder? Der Raspberry Pi 5. Also der
ESP32 ist 3,3. Moment. Mal gucken. 5. 3,3. Ah, nee, der hat auch 3,3. Okay. Äh, welche
Spannung haben die Output-Pins vom Raspberry Pi? 5? 3,3? Zum Glück, zum Glück sind die
meisten Sachen, äh, halten beides aus, aber wenn man halt was hat, was das nicht aushält,
ist halt kaputt. Tja. Aber das Ding ist wirklich praktisch. Denkste, der XP-Leak bringt der
Linux-Community was? Schwer zu sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, was alles geleakt wurde.
Ist das, gibt's das irgendwie auf GitHub oder so? Wenn doch das XP-Source-Code leakt.
On Fortran? Wo denn auch sonst? Warum liegt sowas immer auf Fortran, Alter? Ähm, es
ist eine gute Frage, ob das den Linux-Leuten was bringt. Also, die könnten theoretisch,
wenn so Sachen wie DiodeX dabei sind, DiodeX 9 oder sowas, könnte denen schon was bringen.
Aber ich glaube, so im Großen und Ganzen dürfte es jetzt nicht sonderlich viel ausmachen.
Als ob XP auf GitHub, warum? Der, ähm, der Half-Life Source-Leak war auch auf GitHub.
Der, der Half-Life-Source-Leak, der Team Fortress-Source-Leak und, und des CSGO-Dings war alles, war alles
auf, war alles auf GitHub. Warum sollte, warum sollte der Win auf Source-Code nicht auf
GitHub sein? Wo gibt's denn denn, ich will mir den Source-Code jetzt angucken. Also,
nur mal kurz. Achso, Screenshot oder, Torrent, okay, man muss den Kram sich runterladen.
Also ich glaube, per Torrent ziehe ich mir das nicht. Torrent ist mir ein bisschen zu
monka-toss. Chat meint, es könnte Absicht sein von Microsoft, das glaube ich nicht.
Was hätte Microsoft davon, wenn sie das ausrücken? Da könnten sie es auch offiziell
rausrücken, wenn sie das eh machen wollen. GitHub gehört Microsoft, achja, stimmt, da
habe ich ja gar nicht dran gedacht. Stimmt, ja, ihr habt Recht. Chat, Chat, ihr habt Recht,
ist gut, ja, ist okay. Ey, Sebaro, lass mal. Dann, ne, dann zeige ich den, dann zeige ich
den Source-Code besser nicht im Stream. Äh, Dessortion schreibt, ähm, ich kann es eigentlich
nicht im Channel, der Raspberry Pi ist halt enorm Community, äh, Community, ja, das stimmt.
Wie du sagst, erschwinglich, verständlich, gleich wie beim ESP, gibt auch gute Real-Tech-Chips
im selben Formformat mit, ja, genau, aber das witzige daran ist ja an diesen anderen Chips,
es gibt auch, von Media-Tech gibt es ein paar, es gibt diese STM32, die übrigens schwer
im Kommen sind gerade, ähm, aber die sind teilweise extrem kryptisch zu programmieren.
Man muss ja sagen, dass, gerade weil die Dinge auch Arduino-kompatibel sind, ist das ziemlich
einfach. Ich habe übrigens letztens was gesehen auf, äh, auf Github, irgendeinen Github,
Raspberry Pi, Zero, Go-Image oder sowas. Ah, ich find's nicht mehr. Es hat irgendwie
einer so einen Mini-Linux für den Raspberry Pi gebraucht mit einer Go-Runtime, was angeblich
in 15 Sekunden bootet und da hab ich mir gedacht, hä, 15 Sekunden für so ein Bare-Born-Image
ist ja ganz schön lang und der normale Raspberry Pi Zero, der boot, glaub ich, in 18 Sekunden
oder so. Also, der Unterschied macht ZZ wirklich fett. Du findest das? Dieses Video, zeig mal,
was ist das? Also, WeirdCommons found inside leaked Windows XP source code. Ja gut, da
würd ich mich auch richtig auskotzen, wenn ich Microsoft angestellter wäre und müsste
den Mist programmieren. Hack for PowerPoint. Ja, das kann ich verstehen. Übrigens, man
hat ja damals Microsoft vorgeworfen, sie würden ihre Sachen in Windows, also sie würden
quasi in Windows Funktionen einbauen, die ihre eigenen Funktionen, ihre eigenen Programme
quasi so einen Sonderstatus geben, was halt das hier mal wieder exakt beweist, ne. Also
das Problem haben alle anderen Programme außer PowerPoint. Vom Polwar. Ja und?
Und man will uns die Kram jetzt komplett vorlesen.
Hahahaha.
so our powerpoint friends
can carry on with their dubious practices
the reason for requiring the following test
is now lost in the mists of time
now this app is 32-bit
these bogus timer callbacks
if they really do still occur
could be 16-bit
so we need to add yet more ugliness
in the form of assembler to an app which is
already hardly a paragon of paltritude
okay
excellent fremdwörter
ich hab keine ahnung was das bedeutet
was ist paltritude
was? ich weiß gar
was ist das?
beautiful? what?
beauty
eine ausgeburt der schönheit
sowas quasi
wie gesagt
also sprich eine app die auch nicht gerade
eine ausgeburt der schönheit ist
irgendwie sowas soll das bedeuten glaube
was auch immer
microsoft
ja da ist bestimmt
noch viel mehr drin
und auf das hier
je nachdem was die geleakt haben
wahrscheinlich so gut wie gar keine
weil das
erste windows xp und ich weiß nicht was
geleakt ist das erste oder das zweite windows xp
die haben ja mit
service pack 2 quasi
ein neues windows rausgebracht
evo btw 2 monat excellent
dankeschön für den sub
wo ist der sound
information
die haben ja mit windows xp sp2
das ist ja quasi ein neues windows release
und ich hab irgendwo mal gelesen
das windows
moment was wisst ihr
moment leute ich kriegs nicht mal zusammen
ich sag jetzt einfach mal
service pack 2
service pack 3 gabs nicht
oder moment
gabs service pack 3 für windows?
das bring ich grad durcheinander
ach ne
damals hat die chip so richtig
geil verkackt
die haben damals rausgebracht
windows xp service pack oder was die pc welt
service pack 4
was im prinzip irgendeine custom
patch sammlung
von chip war
und
da wurden die richtig geflamed damals für
service pack 5a
exellent
also es kann sein
dass ich es jetzt durcheinander bringe
mit den windows versionen
und zwar
windows vista
und ich bin mir jetzt echt nicht sicher ob es vista war
wurde nur released
weil microsoft seinen
enterprise kunden
die
einen vertrag mit microsoft hatten
die hatten quasi da ne klausel drinne
dass sie alle
x jahre eine neue windows version
bekommen
so und dann hatte microsoft das problem
sie haben windows xp
sp2 rausgebracht
was eigentlich so gut wie ne neues windows war
deswegen hat die nächste neue windows version
so lang gedauert
und dann haben sie auf dem letzten drücker
noch
noch ein windows released
obwohl es eigentlich noch gar nicht bereit war
dass sie die enterprise kunden nicht verklagen konnten
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das vista war
oder ob das beim wechsel
mit 2000 so war
oder ob das sogar windows 8 war
ich bin mir nicht sicher genau in welcher reinfolge wann das war
aber da sieht man es mal wieder
stonks regiert die welt
egal ob der kram fertig ist oder net
wenn es in deinem enterprise business vertrag
drin steht
dann musst du was raushauen
so jetzt fangen wir mal langsam an
ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher
wo wir stehen geblieben sind
der ranzpeter 70 sagt
hallo hallo ranzpeter
stimmt eigentlich die urzeit jetzt nachdem ich geflasht habe
chat, ihr habt die richtige urzeit
gar nicht zur kenntnis genommen
ist das nicht ein
huge fix
die urzeit stimmt jetzt
und alles was
woran es gelingen hat war das hier
ach es gibt doch den sourcecode von nt 3 5
ok es gibt sachen
die mussten echt nicht sein
das eines davon ist c++
und das andere ist windows nt 3.5
das sind alles so sachen
die muss die welt gar nicht so genau sehen
so wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben
wo haben wir denn aufgehört
sag mal leute wenn ich den font
ein bisschen kleiner mache
wenn ich den font ein bisschen kleiner mache
dann kann man das doch sicherlich
immer noch gut lesen
ich mach mal auf 18
und dann gucken wir mal
kann man doch immer noch gut lesen
oder
oder anders besser
also wie ihr wollt
so sehe ich halt ein bisschen mehr
also so
oder doch lieber so wie
das letzte mal so
das ist fast schon ein bisschen zu fett
was passiert eigentlich
19 sieht bestimmt kacke aus
19 ist exakt so groß wie 18
ne 19
ok machen wir 19
dann ist es so halbe halbe
bei 18 geht auch
ne 19 ist besser
19 ist so ein guter kompromiss
und 69 wäre noch besser
excellent
genau font angepasst
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
wo haben wir denn aufgehört
karl
ok progress bar kann weg
wo haben wir denn aufgehört
ok
ok ich upload nochmal
dann sehen wir was das für eine IP gekriegt hat
irgendeine neue IP hat es auf jeden fall gekriegt
sp1
ja dann ist es noch bevor die das umprogrammiert haben
das ganze windows gedöns
die haben also es gab einen windows xp patch
das war quasi
ne neues windows
a137 ok
das war quasi ne neues windows
ich mach mal
es war entweder sp1 oder sp2
eins vor beiden
aber microsoft wollte kein neues windows rausbringen
mit der version weil sie
ähm
wussten
wie anfällig windows xp
quasi war
und
die haben sich gedacht ok wir beißen den sauren apfel
muss man microsoft ja auch mal zugute halten
und bringen das als service pack raus
deswegen hatten sie danach probleme mit ihren enterprise
business stonks partnern
in time ne neues windows gehabt
deswegen gab es windows xp ja auch so ewig lang
ähm moment mal
muss jemand stehen geblieben
ich muss das mal uploaden
upload fs muss ich nochmal machen
muss nochmal alle files hochladen
terminal
upload
upload fs
exellent
so muss ich aber den
äh hallo
ok
ich musste nochmal die ganzen files hochladen
weil es ansonsten nicht richtig funktioniert hätte
so und jetzt gucken wir mal also wo waren wir stehen geblieben
wir haben
wir konnten schon wir konnten ne index html abrufen
ne
oh ja wenn man das richtig schreibt dann klappt das schon
wo sind wir stehen geblieben
ähm moment post
nein nein nein wir wollen keinen post senden
post hatten post hatten wir als letztes gemacht
ok ich weiß grad nicht mehr genau wo wir stehen geblieben sind
oh exellent
wow was die warum ist der jetzt abgekackt
operation timed out
alles klar warum stürzt der dann ab
ähm ich muss ich brauche jetzt
mal kurz mal ein bisschen Bedenkzeit
äh wo haben wir denn aufgehört
wo haben wir aufgehört also
genau wir haben das fake firmware
update gemacht post
ähm
documents platform IO
projects web server
ok wir gucken ob das fake firmware update noch funktioniert
ok das fake firmware update
funktioniert noch alles klar
ok also post upload
hat funktioniert ich bin mir nämlich echt nicht mehr sicher
wo wir grad aufgehört haben
so dann versuche ich das jetzt nochmal kurz
zu erklären was wir das letzte mal gemacht haben
und zwar das ziel
der ganzen sache ist
den web server zu bauen die minimalste
variante die irgendwie geht
mit dem man ein firmware update hochladen
kann auf sein esp32
wohlgemerkt alles über ssl
also das ist ja grad der witz
also alles über ssl
und das ganze
multithreaded mit mehreren tasks also sprich
ich kann
mich mit zwei clients verbinden
und gleichzeitig connections offen haben
und bekomme bei beiden clients was zurückgeschickt
was mit dem esp32
ganz gut funktioniert weil der esp32
hat erstens zwei cpu kerne
eigentlich drei aber dafür
nur zwei
und hat einen task manager unten drunter
der
die sachen verteilen kann cpu
über zwei cpu cores
deswegen ist auch der einzige grund warum das funktioniert
auf dem esp62
wäre das eine ganze ecke schwieriger
sowas zu basteln wird wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig funktionieren
so
was wir dazu
gemacht haben ist achso genau
dann soll man damit
stinknormalen einfachen statischen
html content abrufen können
und man soll einen firmware update machen können
das wars mehr oder weniger
und die aktuellen
logs sollen man sich abrufen können
sprich das was hier unten gerade
über die serielle schnittstelle kommt
soll man sich auch per get oder so abrufen können
so was jetzt funktioniert
ist folgendermaßen
was schon funktioniert ist folgendes
also server starten
funktioniert
und also key
einlesen vom flash
und
das ganze initialisieren das funktioniert
hier macht er
einen neuen thread auf
oder einen neuen task auf pro verbindung
also sobald sich ein client connectet
macht er einen neuen task auf und ansonsten
guckt er einfach unendlich lange
endlos schleife
wie ob sich ein neuer client verbindet
also
der hängt an der stelle
der hängt quasi zu 99% der zeit hier
mach doch websocket
da müsste ich ja websocket selbst programmieren
ich glaube ich hab keine ahnung
wie man websocket implementiert
kein schimmer
ich glaube das ist nicht so einfach
aber man braucht
nicht mal wirklich websocket
wir machen einfach die verbindung nicht zu
das ist die billigste variante
und hör da nicht auf
neben was sie wird web
das kenn ich nicht
hat das ssl unterstützung
kann das ssl
ok
und den gibts
also der funktioniert auf dem sp32
weil die haben ja
bei manchen sachen
so ein paar limitierungen
den kenn ich noch nicht
also es könnte
funktionieren da bin ich mir
ganz unschlüssig
ja ram usage ist egal
so aber wie gesagt
ich mach das ja auch nicht unbedingt
einfach nur weil ich was fertig
was fertiges kann ich nehmen da gibt es ja noch mehrere sachen
die gehen
ich will mir ja angucken wie man das selbst macht
aber den book mag ich mir mal
vielleicht funktioniert der hier wirklich auf dem sp32
ganz gut also ich denke
der sp286 wird ja nicht funktionieren
müssen wir mal gucken
hast du eine ahnung ob der auf dem sp32 funktioniert
weil denen fehlen ja schon ein paar
standards sachen
die haben ja auch keinen open ssl im eigentlichen sinn
die haben so einen open ssl wrapper
um ihr eigenes ssl gedöns
müsste ich mal ausprobieren
aber ich baue jetzt erstmal
beim eigenen weiter wie gesagt der ist ja nicht dafür
dass ihn jetzt jemand groß benutzen soll
sondern erstens ich will wissen wie es funktioniert
zweitens solange es für mein eigenes zeug funktioniert
ist gut ja und deswegen websocket
selber bauen ist glaube ich nicht so
nicht so die
wahnsinnig gute idee
so
also
hat denn html
html content ausliefern hat ja funktioniert
ich muss jetzt
plus mir grad mal angucken wie das
wo wir stehen geblieben sind
genau also html ausliefern
sollte eigentlich funktionieren
wenn ich es jetzt nicht total verkackt
hab
wir machen ein get
und get
da ist doch die webseite
passt doch
mal gucken ob die webseite noch im browser funktioniert
also das hat schon mal funktioniert
ja firefox ist ein
selbst sein zertifikat das kann nicht funktionieren
ja ok alles klar
huge passwords
ah jetzt geht die seite fast auch immer
ok statischer
content ausliefern funktioniert auch schon mal
absolut huge
webseite
also mega
highly sophisticated
web skills
also das hat funktioniert
so was machen wir denn als nächstes
jetzt lass mal überlegen
ich überleg grad was
noch locks könnten wir machen
firmware update
ist ja erstmal fake
der macht gar kein richtiges firmware update
der tut nur so als macht er ein firmware update
aber das hat funktioniert
das
ja das stimmt das ist tatsächlich eine barrierefreie
webseite wobei
der alttext fehlt
hier müsste noch ein alttext
wenn es richtig barrierefreie
webseite wäre dann wäre das hier alttext
dann würde dann sowas drinstehen wie lachender mann
lul lachender mann
hätte ja noch einen alttext
gebraucht
so
und nach wievor ist
lulw immer noch besser als keckw
das müssen wir uns an der stelle nochmal
klarstellen
also
wir sind stehen geblieben
das hier wird auch abkacken
das wird auch abkacken spätestens
wenn mal eine antwort größer
ist als das was in so einen TCP
P-Paket reinpasst.
Dann wird er nämlich mehrfach senden und das wird abkacken. Einfach abscheißen.
Dürfen wir darauf unsere Webseiten hosten? Natürlich.
Ich meine wir schaffen ganze vier Verbindungen bevor der RAM all ist. Da kann man jede Menge Webseiten hosten.
Also, das bauen wir als erstes ein. Genau. Wir gucken nämlich mal, dass man
nicht so viele Threads aufmachen kann. Ich glaube das ist eine ganz gute Sache. Also es gehen maximal vier Stück.
Es gehen maximal vier, vier Sachen.
Das können wir nämlich mal ausprobieren. Ich mach mal kurz ein Terminal hier neben dran, dass man ein bisschen besser was sieht.
Wie konnte man diesen Mist noch mal auspländen in den Settings?
Settings, irgendwie Map. Map?
Minimap.
Ja, Minimap raus. Weg. Jawoll. Braucht kein Mensch. Benutzt ihr die Minimap?
Ich hab die in Supply and Tax schon immer nicht verwendet.
Weiß gar nicht wofür die gut ist.
In letzter Zeit richtig Stream Marathon. Ja, in letzter Zeit bin ich tatsächlich ziemlich, ziemlich viel on.
This is Serious Marks. Sagt ihr, DHCP Settings.
6.
Exzellent. DHCP V6, so war es aber auch.
IPv6. Das Problem ist, man wird an IPv6 nicht, nicht vorbeikommen.
Also auch im Heimbereich nur begrenzt, weil spätestens, wenn man sich drauf verlassen kann, dass das Internet IPv6 fähig ist,
also sprich, dass man gar keine Seiten mehr braucht, die IPv4 benötigen, beziehungsweise umgedreht gesagt, wenn es die ersten Seiten gibt, die es nur über IPv6 gibt, auf die man drauf will,
dann wird man nicht umherkommen, dass man dem Client auch eine IPv6 Adresse verpasst. Ich mein, theoretisch möglich ist es auch über einen Proxyserver das Ganze zu machen, aber dann braucht der eine IPv6 Adresse.
Aber realistisch betrachtet müssen die Clients auch IPv6 bekommen dann.
Du kannst mit IPv6 auch Ports weiterleiten, da machst du halt eine Firewall-Freischaltung. Das ist zwar nicht Ports-Weiterleiten im eigentlichen Sinne, aber es kommt aufs Gleiche heraus.
So, genau, wir testen jetzt mal, wir testen jetzt mal, wie viele Verbindungen wir zeitgleich hin...
Sag mal, Memory Leak das?
Nee, nicht wirklich, ne?
Scheint nicht zu Memory Leaken. Sieht Sanu gerade auf den ersten Blick so aus. Nee, da Memory Leak nix. Sanu so aus.
So, wir testen jetzt mal, wie viele Verbindungen wir gleichzeitig hinkriegen. Ich überlege jetzt mal, wie viele Verbindungen wir gleichzeitig hinkriegen.
Hatten wir nicht schon mal so eine Wildschleife gebaut dafür? Genau hier, Wildschuhe, Du, bla, bla, bla, 1, 2, 3 Verbindungen. Wir machen 4, 5, 6 Verbindungen. So viel gehen nämlich auf gar keinen Fall.
Du, Curl, maximal 5 Sekunden auf die 32. Das ist jetzt Poggers-Splash-Skills. Und dann machen wir mal ein Sleep. Sogar mal 15 Sleep, dass er sich erholen kann.
Also, das ist eine Endlosschleife mit einer Schleife drin, die 6x Curl startet und eine HTTP-Verbindung, also ein Get-Request macht, maximal 5 Sekunden lang.
Okay, mal gucken. Oh, oh, oh, okay. Also wir kriegen 3 Verbindungen hin. 3 Verbindungen gehen. 3 Verbindungen funktionieren, mehr geht nicht. Danach ist Schluss.
Danach ist Schluss. Außer, dass es auch ordentlich RAM frisst. Cookie Memory Allocate, der kommt schon gar nicht mehr hin. Ne, wir haben sogar 4 Verbindungen, funktioniert mal kurzzeitig.
Excellent. Sag mal, haben wir doch... Okay. Ja, vielleicht sollte ich es doch auf 3 Verbindungen limitieren. Ich limitiere das doch mal auf 3 Verbindungen.
Ich glaube, es ist sonst zu viel RAM. Sonst geht der RAM aus. Zumal das Problem ja auch ist, ich brauche noch ein bisschen RAM für das Main-Programm.
Die Sache ist halt die, dass die ganze SSL-Geschichte braucht halt relativ viel RAM. Das braucht so 30 KB ungefähr pro Verbindung.
Okay, wir schränken das mal ein. Wir schränken das mal ein, dass wir maximal 3 Verbindungen haben können oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ich glaube, Memory Leaks an sich haben wir nicht. Also es wird, glaube ich, alles freigegeben. Das werden wir aber gleich mal ausprobieren.
Wenn wir das beschränkt haben, die Verbindung, dann lasse ich das hier jetzt einfach mal 5 Minuten laufen und gucke, ob der RAM ausgeht.
Aber wir müssen jetzt erstmal beschränken, dass das mehr als 3 Splats machen kann. Machen wir mal irgendwie sowas. Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Mal mal hier oben hin. Exzellent. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie sowas hier. Max Tasks gleich 3. Dann brauchen wir irgendwie sowas wie, jetzt können wir sogar Static machen.
Dann freuen sich die C++-Mans, dass man das auch mal benutzt. Eigentlich können wir auch drauf schreifen, müssen es auch nicht statisch machen.
Das Ergebnis ist eigentlich vollkommen egal. Das ist eh Local zu dem Thread und es wird eh nicht mal rausgeführt sein.
Moment, wir können das doch, was mache ich denn? Wir machen das nicht dahin, sondern wir machen das dahin. Da kommt das hin. Exzellent.
Max Tasks. Dann brauchen wir sowas wie Current Tasks oder sowas. Ist 0. Maximal 3 Tasks gleichzeitig. Aktuelle Anzahl an Tasks ist 0.
Das heißt, sobald wir hier was angenommen haben, müssen wir das hochzählen.
Ne, wir müssen, bevor wir den SSL Handshake machen, müssen wir gucken, ob Current Tasks kleiner Max Tasks ist.
Kleiner oder kleiner gleich? Ne, wir fangen bei 0 an. Ist aber dann kleiner.
Wenn, dann habe ich noch Platz. Wenn ich Platz habe, kann ich den SSL Handshake machen. Gutes.
Wenn nicht, dann sagen wir Else und Printen geben wir eine Fehlermeldung aus. Warning.
Task Limit Reached. Gucken wir, ob das von der Idee her funktioniert, was ich hier treibe.
Also wenn das kleiner ist als das, also sprich, wenn ich noch Tasks frei habe, dann baue ich eine Verbindung auf, ansonsten gebe ich eine Fehlermeldung aus.
Okay, wunderbar. Uploaden wir das Ganze mal. Ach ne, Moment, das müssen wir hier drüber machen.
Das bedeutet, ich kann jetzt 3 Tasks aufbauen und nicht mehr. Von der Idee her müsste das eigentlich funktionieren. Ach so.
Ich bin blöd. Ich habe ganz vergessen, hier Tasks hoch zu zählen. Jetzt kann ich einmalig, ne Moment, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, was ich gemacht habe.
Ich muss hier noch erst sagen, plus plus, so. Ja, das kann nicht funktionieren. Das kann nicht funktionieren.
So und jetzt, ich weiß, dass ich noch was vergessen habe. Ich musste es nämlich, wenn der Task vorbei ist, muss ich das wieder runterzählen.
Aber das ist mir klar. Ich will nur mal ausprobieren, ob es prinzipiell funktioniert. Also sprich, nach der dritten Verbindung sollte es einen Fehler geben und nicht weiter funktionieren.
Mal schauen, ob das klappt. Was ich mir da so überlegt habe.
So, erste Verbindung klappt. Yup, zweite Verbindung sollte auch noch funktionieren.
Joa, zweite Verbindung geht auch. Dritte Verbindung soll auch noch funktionieren. Danach soll es abkacken.
Ja, Task Limit Reached. Warum gebe ich hier eigentlich das Zeug in Warning aus? Ist doch total bescheuert.
Ja, Free Heap Space. Warum gebe ich das überhaupt aus?
Das blickst ja auch durch, wenn ich alles in Warning in Orange ausgib. Gut, das heißt, jetzt müssen wir hier die Tasks wieder runterzählen, dass das funktioniert.
Also sprich, ab drei Tasks gibt es eine Fehlermeldung, Task Limit Reached. Und wenn ein Task fertig ist, dann muss ich das wieder runterzählen.
Wenn man ganz korrekt ist, müsste ich das wahrscheinlich sogar locken, weil er sonst irgendwelche Probleme hat, weil das ja aus einem anderen Thread kommt, aber ich meine, draufgeschissen.
Ey, wird schon nichts passieren. Hast du eigentlich dir die Windows und Office Keys bestellt bei AliExpress? Nee. Könnte man hier nicht einen Semaphore verwenden? Doch.
Dann irgendwie Exclusives. Semaphore fragt mich nicht, was steht Mutex? Irgendwas Exclusive? Ja, Threading Fachbegriffe. Exzellent.
Mutex ist ein Semaphore mit dem Wert 1. Ah, yes. Der Chat ist heute wieder exquisite. Der weiß Bescheid, richtige Hacker-Mans wieder hier.
So, also theoretisch. Nee, wir machen jetzt BigBrain C++17 Feature. Achtung. BigBrain C++17 Feature. Wenn man jetzt von einfällt, wie der Kram funktioniert.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Huge. Standard. Atomic. Und dann irgendwie so einfach, oder? Einfach so?
Yes. So. Jetzt haben wir es hier. Also das sorgt jetzt dafür, das ist auch so ein leicht kryptisches Feature, wo man erstmal 3 Stunden Stack Overflow lesen muss, bis man versteht, was es macht und ab wann es safe ist und ab wann nicht.
Der sorgt dafür, dass das hier, also das spricht Operationen auf diesem Wert, also auf dieser Variable, dass die Atomic sind. Was Atomic ist, ist Folgendes, ich versuche das mal zu erklären.
Wenn eine, kennt ihr, das ist wie bei Datenbanken eine Transaction. Also sprich, man sieht nur den Wert vorher oder den Wert nachher. Dein Mini-Web-Server ist mittlerweile ein Advanced Multi-Threaded Web-Server.
Ja, richtig. Also sprich, wenn was Atomic ist, bedeutet das, die Außenwelt, also wenn ich jetzt die Variable abfragen würde, aus einem anderen Thread, dann würde ich sehen, die ist 0, bis sie 1 ist.
Ich würde entweder 0 sehen oder 1. Ich sehe nur den Wert davor und den Wert danach. Das ist was Atomic Änderung in dem Fall ist. Also sprich, es gibt keinen Stand dazwischen.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier was Neues reinschreibe und doberweise, während der Schreiboperation, mein Thread CPU oder mein Task CPU-Zeit weggenommen bekommt und ein anderer Task läuft und er liest das aus, dann sieht er nicht irgendwie einen unfertigen halbgeschriebenen Zahlenwert, der irgendwie sonst was drin steht, sondern er sieht 0, bis die Operation abgeschlossen ist, dann sieht die Außenwelt 1.
Also sprich, das ist wie eine Transaction quasi in der Datenbank. Es gibt nur davor, es gibt nur danach, es gibt nichts dazwischen.
Zumindest habe ich das immer in irgendeinem C++ Vortrag gehört, was Atomic macht. Das ist so wie Interlock in C Sharp.
Interlock increment. Das ist das gleiche wie in C Sharp das hier. Also sprich, man übergibt eine Referenz auf den Int und dann kann man die Atomic quasi hochzählen.
So und jetzt ist das Ganze sogar komplett Threadsafe, weil es kann nicht passieren, dass irgendeiner darauf zugreift, während der andere schreibt.
So, was hat er hier für Schmerzen? Achso, ich muss das hier noch angeben. Oder aber ich... Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Achso, das ist Atomic Reference. Das heißt, ich muss mit dem und machen. C++, alter Leute, ich bin immer noch schockiert, wie viele Sonderzeichen man die doppelt, dreifach, vierfach, fünffache Bedeutung geben kann.
So, Upload. Jetzt sollte es eigentlich funktionieren, aber maximal drei Tasks. Es ist gerade mal sieben Uhr und draußen sieht es aus wie Nacht. Ja, leider. Und es ist richtig Kackwetter.
Dafür funktioniert die Nachtsicht von meiner neuen Kamera im Hof ziemlich gut. Ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen kann, weil ich sonst meine Mutter im Flur liege.
Ich habe mich gerade auf die Vorschau geguckt. So, da kommt eine Katze rein bei mir. Katz, was ist los? Mein Chatoverlay... Was, mein Chatoverlay ist kaputt? Nee, das funktioniert.
Also bei mir im Vorschau ist die letzte Meldung, die ich sehe, ist dein Chatoverlay kaputt. Also das muss eigentlich funktionieren.
Nee, da ist es doch. Funktioniert das, Chatoverlay. Wie kommst du drauf, dass es kaputt ist? She baited. You got she baited. So, habe ich jetzt abgeloaded. Okay, schauen wir mal.
Also, Verbindung geht. Jawoll. Nächste Verbindung. Auch. Nächste Verbindung. Auch. So, das letzte Mal ist es abgekackt und sollte wieder funktionieren.
Excellent. So, und jetzt können wir mal unseren Test machen und dann sehen wir auch, ob wir irgendeinen Memory Leak drin haben. Ich führ jetzt einfach mal 1-2 Minuten lang 6 parallele Verbindungen auf die Kiste aus und hoffe, er kackt nicht ab und er limitiert bei maximal 3 Verbindungen.
Was machst du eigentlich beruflich? Mach mal Ausrufe, Zeichen, Beruf. Ich hab das extra ein Clip dazu aufgenommen. Guck mal, es hat funktioniert.
Task Limit Reach. Guck, 3 Stück haben funktioniert, 3 Stück nicht. Exquisite. So, jetzt müssen wir mal schauen, ob wir irgendwelche Memory Leaks haben. Also hier 1-6-6. So, quatschen wir mal den nächsten Durchlauf ab.
Also von den anderen 3 schlagen 2 fehlen, seh ich das richtig? Aber auch nicht gut. Aber es müsste jetzt eigentlich funktionieren. Okay, jetzt ist nur einer fehlgeschlagen.
Okay, das ist glaube ich ein bisschen random. Aber das ist okay, das Ding stürzt jetzt wenigstens nicht mehr ab. Die Musik ist vorbei.
Sebaru, ich mach die Telekom wieder Paints Champ bei dir. Also ich würde sagen, wir haben keinen Memory Leak. Also wir sind jetzt bei 165 und die ganze Zeit eiern wir so ein bisschen.
Also ich würde sagen, wir haben keinen Memory Leak. Also wir sind jetzt bei 165 und die ganze Zeit eiern wir so bei 165 rum. 165 Kilobyte frei. 165, ja.
Okay, also anscheinend haben wir das in so weit ordentlich programmiert, dass wir zumindest mal keinen Memory Leak produziert haben. Das ist doch auch schon mal was.
So, also jetzt haben wir das ganze limitiert. Was möchte der mir hier eigentlich sagen, wenn ich das hier anklicke? Ach nee, das ist diese Big Brain Visual Studio Code Extension, die highlightet, wie lange ein Block geht. Verstehe.
Also es schwankt ein bisschen, aber im Prinzip glaube ich haben wir keinen Memory Leak.
Wie viel RAM hat der Controller eigentlich? Also dynamisch nutzbar sind, glaube ich, maximal 240 oder so Kilobyte.
Was hier jetzt das RAM frisst, ist einmal das Display und ein bisschen Arduino würde ich sagen. Das Display frisst auch mal ungefähr 60 Kilobyte RAM.
Aber das kann ich verstehen, weil das sind ja 128 x 64 oder irgendwie so was Pixel und wir machen ja auch die nicht speicher schonende Variante mit Sprites.
Also wir malen das mit einzelnen Sprites auf das Display, weil es da nicht flickert. Also das Display braucht halt ein bisschen RAM.
Du hast fast eine Minute Delay und das ist aber schlecht. Darf ich hier links zu GIFs posten? Ja, es sei denn es sind irgendwelche Gatschi-Buzz GIFs oder so.
Also nur ordentliches Zeug. Oh, was ist das jetzt für ein Schmerz? Alles failed, Alter. Task Limit Reached.
Warum gibt ihr mir nicht mehr aus, Task Limit Reached? Irgendwas ist kaputt, irgendwas ist kaputt.
Sollte man eigentlich ausgehen im Task Limit? Hä? Okay.
Doch in der SSL geht noch, sonst kriegst du keine Antwort. Nur manchmal geht es nicht, halt bei manchen Tasks, das ist schon okay.
Also das scheint ganz gut zu funktionieren. Warum möchte Visual Studio Code eigentlich das einrücken, genau hier unten drunter? Könnte man das nicht dazu überreden, das irgendwie hier hinein zu rücken? Nein, kann man nicht.
So, also jetzt haben wir das ganze limitiert. Jetzt kommen wir mal zu den eigentlichen Sachen und zwar, ach so, muss man den Kram hier locken?
Ich hab da so eine dofe Vermutung, dass das wahrscheinlich einfach random crash zwischendurch. Weil die sagen selbst, dass sie nicht multithreaded saves sind.
Und die sagen selbst, die sagen, warte mal, wo steht es denn hier?
Genau, entweder man lockt selbst oder, genau, die sagen, also die Funktionen, die in den Kontext verwenden, ist sicher, aber manche Funktionen benutzen unter der Haube den gleichen Speicher.
Also da muss ich wirklich irgendwie locken, das ganze. Genau, vor Beispiel SSL-Kontext, kein Point to an SR-Private Key, das haben wir hier und wir hatten es das letzte Mal auch schon, dass das random gecrashed ist.
Also sprich, überall, wo ich, ne, eigentlich nur das hier. Deswegen nur Funktional programmieren. Exzellente Idee.
Also das hier müssen wir auf jeden Fall locken. Einfach nur einen Thread gleichzeitig benutzen. Ja, stimmt, warum bin ich nicht vorher auf die Idee gekommen?
Einfach alles mit einem Thread machen. Ich mein, man könnte, das war auch ne Sache, die hab ich mir am Anfang überlegt, ob man nicht einfach so ne Art Message Loop macht.
Also sprich, man macht einen Thread, aber das innen drin halt nach Möglichkeit Non-Blocking, aber das Non-Blocking zu machen, sacked, Alter. Das ist übelst kacke.
Und du hast das Problem, dass du entweder eine CPU komplett dicht machst oder da irgendwie unterschiedliche, keine Ahnung, alle 500 Millisekunden mal laufen lassen musst und sowas.
Ich find so eigentlich die schönere Variante. So, jetzt muss ich mir nur mal überlegen, was müssen wir jetzt eigentlich locken hier drin, dass das passt.
Ist das eigentlich okay, wenn man sowas hier macht? Weil die Sache ist die, ich hab mir ja nen C++ Webcast letztens angeguckt.
Und die haben gesagt, dass das C++, ne warte mal, wie war das? Ich weiß nicht mehr nach was ich gesucht hab. Ich hab irgendeine C-Sharp zu C++ Vergleich gesucht und die haben gesagt, das geht in C++ nicht so einfach, aber man könnte quasi Static Sachen, Static Variablen in einer Methode machen.
Static Variablen in einer Methode verwenden und die würden nur einmal initialisiert.
Kannst du bitte Onstream ein Strukturgramm von deinem Code auspapieren? Ah, yes Strukturgramm, excel. Habt ihr einen guten Strukturgramm Maker online?
Dann probier ich mal ein Strukturgramm zu malen für irgendwas ganz Simples und ihr könnt mich failen sehen beim Strukturgramm malen, weil ich hab das seit meiner Ausbildung nicht mehr gemacht und Strukturgramme sind auch der übelste Scheiß.
So eine Kacke. Ein Nasty Schneiderman Diagramm, genau. Wir könnten auch ein UML Diagramm malen von der Minisurf Klasse.
Chat, was meint ihr was besser, ein UML Diagramm oder ein Strukturgramm? Strukturgramme sind komplett useless, übelster Kacke. Papp, wisst ihr was auch richtig nice ist? Wir könnten auch ein Ishikawa Diagramm malen, auch so was ganz tolles.
Excellent. Problem. Das ist auch so was tolles. Papp können wir auch malen. Ok, mal kurz Big Brain machen. Wie locken wir das Ganze richtig?
Ja, ich hoffe das ist ok so, dass man das hier inline macht. Also wie locken wir das Ganze? Ich weiß gar nicht. Also das muss ich auf jeden Fall locken. Das Setup muss ich auf jeden Fall locken.
Das ist sicher, das muss ich locken, da komme ich nicht drum herum. Ok, lock, lock ist vielleicht ein bisschen, ja so, unlock.
Übrigens, was das macht, vielleicht für Leute, die multithreaded mäßig nicht so eingeweiht sind. Also erstens muss man sagen, generell multithreaded Sachen programmieren ist oftmals, der Fehler steckt im Detail, es ist oftmals schwerer als auf den ersten Blick den Anschein hat.
Das hier sorgt dafür, dass diese Stelle nur von einem Thread ausgeführt werden darf. Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt zwei Verbindungen gleichzeitig aufmache, die erste Verbindung, die an dieser Stelle ankommt, schließt das hier ab, führt das hier aus und macht hier weiter.
Und die andere Verbindung hängt an der Stelle so lang, bis die erste Verbindung fertig ist. So, also das muss ich auf jeden Fall locken, dass ich keine Fehler kriege. Und wahrscheinlich, ich vermute mal, das hier auch vermute mal das hier auch, weil das auch auf eine externe Ressource zugreift.
Man könnte auch Wild True drum herumschreiben, das geht natürlich auch. So, ich glaube, das war's. Ansonsten, wir uploaden, dann gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert. Und während wir weiter basteln, lass ich im Hintergrund mal meine Wild Schleife da im Kreis laufen und gucke, ob es crashed.
Okay. So, ich hoffe, das reicht, was man locken muss. Ansonsten wird es zu advanced. Wir machen einfach mal nur drei, um gut es zack.
Guck mal, der ist schon mit zwei Verbindungen teilweise überfordert. Ich glaube, das liegt aber daran, weil zu viel gleichzeitig ist. Wenn er ein kleines Delay macht zwischen den Verbindungen, dann geht's wahrscheinlich.
Der braucht nur beim Handshake so viel. Okay, ich lasse das jetzt einfach mal laufen und wir gucken weiter.
So, das irritiert mich, wenn das hier neben rumläuft. Moment, ich muss das mal kurz ausblenden. Ich kann mir das Geflimmer nicht angucken daneben.
Die Zahl sagt freier RAM, wie viel speicherfrei ist. Du siehst auch, bei jedem Verbindungsversuch geht der RAM runter.
Ich baue gerade aktuell drei Verbindungen gleichzeitig auf. Da ist er am Ende mit dem RAM. So, und jetzt kommen wir mal zur eigentlich wichtigen Geschichte.
Eines der Sachen, warum ich überhaupt angefangen habe, den RAM zu basteln. Und zwar, dass man Locks darüber abrufen kann. Also, wir haben hier für Updates, Handle Locks.
Ich kann mal was gucken, ob ich... Ach, das wird schon passen. Okay, also wir müssen die Locks erstmal da rein kriegen.
Also, Handle Locks. Also, eines der Sachen, warum ich sowas mal basteln wollte, ist, die ganzen seriellen Ausgaben an Locks, die man hier bekommt.
Das ist ja schön und gut, wenn der Controller am PC hängt, dass man das auch abfragen kann. Aber, wenn das Ding im WLAN hängt, warum überhaupt mit SSL? Das ist ganz einfach, weil ich wissen will, wie es funktioniert.
Und für Firmware Update. Firmware Update mit SSL ist mir lieber. Ich meine, wir haben Firmware Update über SSL mit Basic OS. Also, besser geht es ja wohl nicht mehr.
An sich ist kein Problem. Ich meine, das ist im privaten WLAN, da ist eh nichts. Aber ich finde es schöner Firmware Update über SSL. Und hauptsächlich, weil es geht.
So, also haben wir irgendwie sowas. Handle, Handle Locks. Handle Get Locks. Ich brauche einen SSL-Kontext. Und das war's.
Jetzt machen wir mal einen Test. Einfach Firmware signieren. Das ist ein Punkt, den habe ich mir auch aufgeschrieben. Das wollte ich schon ewig mal ausprobieren. Ich habe es bis jetzt nicht gecheckt, wie das ordentlich funktioniert.
Das ist Big Brain. Nein, das kann kein WPA3. Oh, Leute, wir haben mich richtig gelockt. RIP. Random Crash. Wo ist er gecrashed? An. Function. Alter. Please. Ordentliche Fehlermeldung. Was ist das denn? Helper. 239, das ist im Print. Nee, Run. Task Run. Standard Function.
Wo ist er denn gecrashed? 228 ist er gecrashed. 228. 22, was? Moment, wo? Wo? 228. Ja, hier. Ja, gut. Das sagt jetzt eigentlich, das sagt ja eigentlich nur, dass er in diesem Task irgendwo gecrashed ist.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr. Okay, beim Text ausgeben ist er gecrashed. Big Brain Logger heißt das Ding. So muss das sein. Alter, ist das... Ah, ist das ernst?
Okay. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo er genau gecrashed ist, aber ich wette mit euch. Ich schwör auf Twitch Sub, Alter. Das liegt daran, dass ich die Sachen nicht richtig logge hier. 100 pro. Ich bin mir da ziemlich sicher.
Okay. To do. Fix me. Okay. Sucked. Alter. So, das muss ich nochmal neu machen. Das reicht nicht. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich muss ich das Free noch locken. Nee, ich muss den Handshake locken. Na klar, ich muss...
Der Handshake ist das eigentliche Problem. 100 pro, weil während er den SSL Handshake macht, muss der garantiert auch den Private Key lesen und sowas. Sonst funktioniert das doch gar nicht.
Ich muss 100 pro den Handshake locken. So, und warum das jetzt so lange ohne Fehler, guck, schon wieder gecrashed. Und wisst ihr, warum das so random auftritt? Weil Multithreading-Fehler immer random auftreten.
Was für mich nicht auf einen anderen Fehler schließt. Multithreading-Fehler sind immer so random. Und der Chat hat das gewusst. Der Chat ist ja auch mega big brain. Vor allem bei den ganzen Subs in letzter Zeit.
Wo haben wir denn unser big brain, Moment. Nein, wo habe ich es denn? Huge big brain Chat. So, ich lock das nicht richtig. Elevenhead ist der Chat heute schon.
So, also das ist nicht richtig gelockt. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. So, jetzt ist die Frage, bauen wir erst... Ich mache jetzt erst mal das eine fertig, wo ich gerade stehen geblieben bin.
Äh, Moment, wenn ich jetzt das finden würde, wo habe ich denn aufgehört? Ja. Also, wenn der Part locks ist, dann machen wir Handle, get locks und dann geben wir die Referenz auf das SSL Ding.
So. Ähm, ich probiere jetzt mal was aus. Ja, Mülldreck, so ist es. Ich glaube, ich muss... Guck hier, da ist wieder gecrashed.
Das legt 100% daran, dass ich das nicht richtig locke. Garantiert. Aber ich probiere das jetzt erstmal mit den locks aus.
Ähm, so. Und was ich mir gedacht habe, wir können Folgendes machen. Ich will ja, dass ich diese locks hier unten, was ich seriell ausgebe, dass ich die über eine Webverbindung bekomme.
Weil, wenn ich irgendwie das Ding im W-Lan hängen habe und einen Firmware-Update mache oder sonst was, oder irgendwas debuggen muss und das Ding hängt halt im W-Lan und nicht seriell bei mir dran, zum Beispiel weil ich es in der Türgegen-Sprecher-Lage eingebaut habe oder das im Keller hängt oder sonst wo, dann brauche ich natürlich Lock-Ausgabe über HTTP.
So, und ich habe mir gedacht, wir könnten das folgendermaßen machen. Wenn wir einen Curl machen. Ich breche das mal kurz ab hier. Ähm, bevor es jetzt wieder ganze Zeit crash. Wenn wir einen Curl machen, also wenn wir einen Request machen.
Auf, hallo. Auf, ähm, ich mach mal hier. Auf slash locks. Das geht aktuell nicht. Der hängt und sagt empty reply. So, aber was wir machen können ist folgendes.
Ähm, also man aktuell macht SSL-Handshake, geht dann hier rein, Handle-Locks und hier ist halt nichts drin. So.
Ja, mit Websockets wäre das easy, aber ich habe keinen Bock, Websockets selbst zu programmieren. Wir werden die einfachste Variante überhaupt machen, die wahrscheinlich, ähm, funktioniert, aber eventuell den Browser durcheinander bringt.
Müssen wir mal gucken. Und zwar, wir lassen einfach die Verbindung auf. Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert. Also sprich, wir machen jetzt einfach sowas hier. While, true. Also das ist jetzt nur zum testen.
Ja. Wir machen einfach die Verbindung nie zu. So, und delay, eine Sekunde. Und jetzt sagen wir send, string. Ich mein, wir machen jetzt testmäßig mal was. SSL, äh, keine Ahnung. Tests, eins, zwei, drei. Nee, wie macht man das? Golden, kappa, check, eins, zwei, drei. Genau.
So. Äh, alles klar. Der braucht ein bisschen. Upload. Gibt es eigentlich den golden kappa noch? Schon ewig nicht mehr gesehen.
So, und von der Idee her, was der jetzt machen sollte, der sollte unendlich, oh, äh, haben wir was vergessen? Nee, ich hab nichts vergessen. Der sollte jetzt unendlich lang antworten. Golden kappa, check, eins, zwei, drei. Und die Verbindung nie zu machen. Außer vielleicht nahe 15 Minuten oder so. Aber dann kann ich die einfach neu aufbauen.
Oh, what? Ah, ich, ich, ah, ich weiß was, chat, wisst ihr was ich verkehrt gemacht hab? Ich sende ja überhaupt keine Header zurück. Ich muss ja, ich muss ja Header zurück senden. Weil, weil ansonsten weiß der ja gar nicht ob es funktioniert.
Also ich muss, bevor ich in diese Schleife hier gehe, muss ich dem erstmal einen HTTP Content-Type, Content-Type TextHTML, ja meinetwegen TextHTML, wenn es sein muss. Das ist nicht wirklich HTML, nee Textplain ist das hier.
Ähm, ich muss ihm den Header zurück senden, weil ansonsten ist es ja kein gültiger HTTP-Request. Ich muss ihm erstmal sagen, HTTP okay und Content-Type Textplain und dann kann ich Zeug senden. Das, das müsste jetzt funktionieren. Send.
So, hallo, Visual Studio, respond. Also ich muss euch sagen, ich mag die C++-Extension von Visual Studio Code nicht. Die ist einfach kacke lahm.
HTTP Persistent Connection. Also wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, wir können das gerade mal aufmachen. Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, ist das sogar valid was ich hier mache. Mit Connection einfach auflassen.
Okay, Chunk Transfer könnte man machen. Das ist die saubere Variante wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich ist Chunk Transfer die saubere Variante. Connection Keep Alive.
All Connections are considered persistent. Ja, dann ist das sogar valid was ich mache. Also ich lasse die Verbindung einfach auf und sende. Warum programmierst du einen Webserver? Weil ich wissen will wie es funktioniert und weil mir die bisherigen Webserver, die ich getestet habe von ESP32 nicht so gut gefallen haben.
Der eine hat sich in irgendeinem Fall die Entschlusschleifen aufgehangen und der andere hat Multiswitch Probleme gehabt. Deswegen wollte ich so einen Mini-Webserver mal selbst programmieren. Erstens um zu gucken wie es geht. Und zweitens, dass der genau das macht was ich brauche und nicht mehr. Nämlich Logs, Firmware Update und Statisches Index HTML. Fertig.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert. Also wenn das klappt. Das wird für den ESP32. Ja, oben rechts. Guck mal. Oben rechts sieht man noch das AJAJA Board. So, ähm. Und unten. So, der sollte jetzt eigentlich einen valid header zurückschicken. Und dann unendlich lange Golden Kappa Check 123 schreiben.
Bäm. Future Chat. Jetzt wird er am Start. So, ich frage mich jetzt wie lange der das macht.
Gut, der wird das jetzt machen bis die Verbindung abbricht. Und wenn die Verbindung abbricht dann. Ah, ich habe eine Sache vergessen. If not, break.
Also sprich, wenn das Senden nicht klappt. Also sprich, wenn dieses Write hier fehlt schlägt. Wenn das Senden nicht klappt, dann muss ich nämlich einen Break machen. Weil ansonsten bleibt der für immer und ewig in dieser Schleife hier hängen.
Auf YouTube würdest du sehen, ja. Dann könntest du sehen, wann er einfach da crasht, ja. Okay, exellent. Oh, jetzt haben wir hier Big Brain Frage im Chat. Huge Wall of Text. Also, Hey Max, mir wurde heute dein Video von 2013 vorgeschlagen. What?
YouTube wird auch wieder voll dabei, wo du über die Berufsausbildung zum Fachinformatiker System Integration geredet hast. Und du meintest, dass man Glück haben muss, wenn man in einem Betrieb angestellt wird, dass man nicht nur Druck hat. Nee, das habe ich glaube ich anders. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich so gesagt habe.
Das habe ich auf jeden Fall anders gemeint. Ich meinte damit, wenn man, oder umgedreht hat, ich meinte, wenn man Pech hat, landet man in einem Laden, wo man nur Druckerpatronen wechseln muss. Also umgedreht.
Also die meisten Jobs sollten sich glücklicherweise nicht mit Druckerpatronen wechseln beschäftigen. So, ich habe jetzt zum 1. September meine Ausbildung angefangen. Exellent.
Und bin seitdem in einem Projekt für die Umstrukturierung von einem Schulkampus. Okay, ja die haben ja chronisch, die sind ja chronisch unterbesetzt, was IT Leute angeht in der Schule. So, ich konnte auch schon einen Switch konfigurieren mit Hilfe und einbauen.
Patchen, ETC. Dazu hatte ich diese Woche auch das erste Mal die Berufsschule. Ohje, und? Und? Und jeder sollte mal erzählen, was er bis jetzt alles im Betrieb machen konnte. Und viele haben eigentlich nur Standardzeug gemacht, wie Druckerpatronen wechseln oder einen Bildschirm anschließen.
Ja, die meisten, also nein, die meisten stimmt nicht. Die meisten Jobs sind nicht Druckerpatronen wechseln, aber es gibt leider zu viele Jobs in dieser Richtung. Man könnte jetzt sagen, irgendeiner muss es ja machen, aber dazu brauchst du eigentlich kein Physi.
Ja. Und es kommt natürlich auch auf den Betrieb an. Also man hat ja schon da Einfluss drauf. Man bekommt ja meistens einen ganz guten Eindruck davon, auf was es für ein Laden ist. Also auch vorher schon. Und Berufsschule ist Payne's Champ, aber richtig. Und wie findest du die Berufsschule bis jetzt?
Also wahrscheinlich hat es ja schon mehr als einen Tag. Oder habt, oder habt ihr keinen Blogunterricht und habt quasi einmal die Woche Berufsschule oder wie ist das bei euch? Also wir hatten es immer so. Wir hatten dann irgendwie teilweise vier, fünf Wochen am Stück Berufsschule.
Und das fand ich immer geil. Das fand ich immer geil, weil Berufsschule an sich ist zwar kacke, aber Berufsschule ist Berufsschule. Deswegen war das immer vier, fünf Wochen Urlaub.
Berufsschule ist Erholung pur gewesen. Deine Ausbildung hat mit Kobold begonnen. Oh, Massive Payne's Champ. Wir machen an Weihnachten einen Kobold Stream.
Das hat der Chat mich dazu überredet.
Austausch mit den Mitschülern war bei uns kacke wie immer. Weil ihr wisst ja, wie gern ich andere Leute habe. Bis auf drei, vier Leute konnte ich da keinen leiden. Und wir sind alle auf den Sack gegangen. Aber so ist das halt mit anderen Menschen im Real Life.
Vor allem was bei uns ätzend war, da hatten wir Leute, die kamen gerade frisch aus der Schule mit 16 oder so und da war teilweise so Idioten dabei. Aber gut, ich war ja damals auch schon 23 oder so oder 24. Ich war ja auch schon einer der etwas älteren in der Berufsschule. Wahrscheinlich kommt es einem einfach nur blöd vor und man war selbst so blöd.
Gut, also das funktioniert. Oh, oh, guck mal. Warum ist da so viel Speicher weg? Ah, weil Endlosschleife. Guck mal Leute, das ist genau das was ich gesagt habe. Bevor ich das Break hier reingemacht habe, da bleibt es in der Endlosschleife hängen.
Und zack. Und er gibt nicht frei. Ich muss erst mal neu uploaden. Dann gibt er wieder frei. Ich hatte hier keinen Break drin, was natürlich ziemlich auf Fail ist. So und jetzt ist der nächste Knackpunkt. Ich kann jetzt zwar Golden Kappa Check 1, 2, 3 und endlich zurücksenden. Schön und gut. Aber eigentlich will ich ja Logs zurücksenden und nicht Golden Kappa Check 1, 2, 3.
Erst mal gucken, ob das Memory Leak weg ist. Also unser Englischlehrer war eigentlich komplett für'n Arsch, weil der ist quasi nach uns in Rente gegangen und dementsprechend war ihm auch alles egal.
So, mal gucken, ob der jetzt Speicher freigibt. Ah, yes, Speicher freigegeben, sehr gut. Um's nochmal zu sagen, also ich war ja auf der hier. Ich war ja auf der Berufsschule mit sagenhaften 2,1 Sternen bei Google. Und die sieht halt echt aus wie im Knast.
Diese Berufsschule. Das ist übrigens fake, dass die so glücklich sind. Die sind nicht glücklich. Die tun nur so. Davon kenn ich keinen einzigen Lehrer mehr. Sind das Lehrer?
Doch. Das ist mein ehemaliger Netzwerktechniklehrer. Das ist der Herr Heinzel. Den kenn ich noch. Pongos. Will ich jetzt einer auf den Bildern?
Ja, aber dass die alle so glücklich sind, ist fake. Es sieht wirklich aus wie im Knast, oder? Es sieht aus wie in einem Wachturm. Es sieht original aus wie im Knast.
Diese Schule. Ich hab mich damals schon gefragt, warum hat die Schule einen Wachturm? G-Bait Spende.
Was ist da mit Sebaro?
Ne, dafür musst du nicht timeouten. Das ist schon okay. So ein bisschen G-Bait ist okay.
Guck mal, wie glücklich die alle sind.
Na gut. Aber auch kein Corona.
Ja, zumindest diese Schule hat mega gesackt einfach nur. Und 2,1 Sterne sind fast noch zu viel.
Ja, hat er recht. Ein großer Stream ist es ja nicht. Die Schule sah früher wie im Knast aus und hatte die schlechteste Kaffeteria überhaupt.
Also bei der Kaffeteria hast du dir bestimmt irgendwelche Darmkrankheiten geholt, wenn du da länger als ein halbes Jahr gegessen hast. Die Chancen waren hoch.
Das ist ein Abschlussfoto und Freunde, dass sie alle zu Ende sind. Ja, das könnte natürlich auch sein.
Exzellent. So, aber weiter im Text. Also Golden Kappa Check 1,2,3 senden, das funktioniert. Aber Speicher freigeben funktioniert auch. Das ist doch schon mal was. Okay.
Aber Speicher freigeben, jawoll. Funktion auch. Gut, der eigentliche Sinn ist ja aber, dass ich Logs zurückschicken kann. Also zum Beispiel das hier.
So, Logs zurückschicken. Also ich will jetzt das, was ich hier reinschreibe, dahin schicken.
So, dann brauchen wir erstmal hier irgendwas, um Logs zu schreiben. Wo hört dann diese Funktion hier auf?
Äh, da. Also Void. Wie nennen wir das mal? Push Logs. Geht eigentlich sowas hier in Methode? Nee, oder? Das geht nicht. Oder? Nee.
Hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, weil er weiß ja gar nicht, was das ist. Geht. Moment, aber sowas müsste doch gehen.
Warum geht das nicht?
Da müsste doch der Compiler eigentlich schlau genug sein, rauszufinden, was es ist für nen Typ. Aber ich hinterfrag sowas gar nicht.
Äh, was war er? Message oder so? Oder? Vlog. Message, message. Wer nennt's message?
So, jetzt muss ich das schreiben. Wie krieg ich denn das jetzt gebacken? Also ich schreib von hier, ich mach das jetzt hier mal weg.
Ähm. Push Logs. Free Heap Space. So.
So also
Ne wir machen einen counter das ist besser dann sehe ich auch dass es funktioniert einfach in den easy mode counter
CNT plus plus so
also von der idee her sollte der jetzt versuchen einmal pro schleifen durchlauf locks zu pushen
an den client wie kriege ich ihm das denn beigebracht
wie kriege ich das hin aus meinem main task an die clients zu pushen ok das wird
das ein bisschen komplizierter also ich meine hier immer das gleiche pushen ist ja klar das
funktioniert ich war wir können wir können das erst mal total easy mode machen wir können
das total easy mode machen wir machen einfach ich brauche die instanz habe ich schon das ist
eine methode von der klasse ich habe da schon zugriff drauf ich weiß nur nicht wie ich das wie
ich das gebacken kriege dass ich das ich muss das queueen irgendwie also sprich das hier wird ja
von meinem main task aufgerufen allerdings die connection zum client ist ein eigener task
also ok wir machen mal die billig variante irgendwie sowas keine ahnung message einfach
irgendwie sowas wir tasten uns mal ein bisschen ran so und jetzt senden wenn ich golden kappa
check sondern message mir ist klar dass das multithread nicht gut funktioniert weil
gemeinsam zu griff und sonst was ja also ich will aber das müsste erst mal gucken ob das
prinzipiell funktioniert was ich mir ausmale so und jetzt sagen wir einfach message gleich
im moment no come on bra visual studio code underscore message underscore message
so und jetzt ok jetzt sollte er nicht mal golden kappa check pushen sondern er sollte jetzt alle
message was not declared underscore message wenn schon muss man doch richtig machen so
er sollte jetzt jede sekunde hier diesen counter diesen counter stand pushen mal gucken ob das
funktioniert wie gesagt multithreaded wird das laufend mal crashen weil der überschreibt das
während ich das hier sende und so das ist also schön es kann wie gesagt ich mir ist klar dass
es nicht funktioniert ich will bloß gucken ob das prinzipiell so geht wie ich mir das vorstelle
so wir müssen auf jeden fall noch locken ok ok das das funktioniert also jede sekunde krieg ich den
stand vom counter geschickt ist halt jetzt timing ein bisschen unglücklich aber ok so und jetzt
können wir jetzt können wir gleich mal zugucken wie das ganze crash jetzt gucken wir mal zu wie
das ganze crash weil ich nehme das delay raus und lasse jetzt so schnell wie es geht sachen da
pushen das das wird das wird instant crashen einfach nur jetzt oder ziemlich schnell crashen
auf jeden fall gar nicht na gut ich sende ja auch nur ich sende ja auch nur jede sekunde dann ist
die chance dass es crash kann immer so hoch ok ich muss das öfter senden aber das ist doof das
sagt richtig also das problem ist jetzt ich sende jetzt ja nur jede sekunde was was doof ist da
verpasst ich ja viel also was jetzt was jetzt viel cooler wäre wenn wenn ich von hier irgendwie den
kleinen task benachrichtigen könnte dass es neue locks gibt ich habe eine idee was wir machen können
wir machen also es gibt ja wenn ich das delay rausnehmen habe ich massig text ja das kann ich
vorher noch mal machen schnell wir machen mal wir machen auf 50 millisekunden delay weil ich will
nicht dass der abkackt wegen zu viel load auf einem kern also es gibt was eingebaut in in diesem
unter unterliegenden task scheduler vom vom esp 32 da kann man blocken bis man eine nachricht
bekommt genau ich ich werde ich werde die nachrichten jetzt auch kühnen das ist das
was ich vor habe allerdings nicht mit der standard c++ q sondern mit der eingebauten
q weil die ist schon task thread safe warum crash da nix das erscheint mir jetzt sehr
unrealistisch dass da nix krascht ok ich nehme ich nehme das delay mal komplett raus aber jetzt
spätestens jetzt wird er kraschen wir kühnen das jetzt auch gleich
auf
warum krascht das denn nicht kann mir das irgendjemand logischer logischer
erklären warum das nicht krascht warum krascht das nicht verstehe ich nicht
ok
das muss doch kraschen ich mein nur mal von der idee her warum das eigentlich kraschen
muss ich schieb hier mein text rein so der text weiß diese variabel zu ohne lock ohne
alles was im endeffekt heißt was im endeffekt heißt es kann sein dass während ich das auf an
den client sende die sache schon gelöscht wird also das senden dauert ja ein paar millisekunden
und in der zeit kann sein dass der alte string schon aufgeräumt wird also dass ich ich würde
sagen dass es eher klicks glück dass das gerade funktioniert und wir können es mal ausprobieren
ich sende mal ein bisschen längeren text ich sende mal ein bisschen längeren text und ich bin
mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher dass das kraschen muss das hat mir das ist auch selten dass ich
versuche was zu kraschen zu bringen dass es nicht automatisch krascht sehr merkwürdig
auf jeden fall sehr merkwürdig aber trotzdem mir fällt darauf trotzdem ist es eine scheiß
lösung weil dieser thread hier ein cpu kern quasi komplett blockiert also das ist ja eine
endlose schleife ohne jegliches delay ohne jegliches weight drin und auch ohne keck weight also
komplett ohne weight so jetzt kreischt ne auch nicht ok leute ich habe keine ahnung warum das
kreischt warum es nicht kreischt aber trotzdem ist die lösung kacke also erstens sollte es
kraschen und es wird wahrscheinlich auch unglücklicherweise ab und zu mal kraschen
und das zweite ist das hier macht einen cpu kern voll ich habe aber eine andere idee wir
machen das jetzt so wir plocken das mach mal aus dem kopierten string eine referenz ja
nee dann dann dann kackt es auf jeden fall ab wobei nee dann kackt es nicht ab weil weil
das hier hier wird ja kopiert hier wird ja hier wird ja noch mal kopiert also wie geht
man das konst und ist das ist das die richtige syntax c++ oder oder oder ist es oder ist
es konst und ach du scheiße nee ok es ist es ist konst und excellent alles klar die
haben es echt geschafft die haben es echt geschafft wirklich mittlerweile jedem zeichen
acht bedeutung zu geben in c++ so das wird das wird jetzt weiterhin funktionieren oder
random kraschen wie es vorher hätte schon machen sollen aber hier kopiert er ja den
inhalt also ich vermute mal so bei einer einfachen zu weit das wird den inhalt kopieren aber
trotzdem wundert es mich dass es nicht krascht keck stable na gut so aber es ist trotzdem
eine kacke lösung weil pass mal auf wenn ich wenn ich das mehrfach starte ich leite
mal kurz das da nach der null um wenn ich das mehrfach achso nee abbrechen wenn ich
das mehrfach starte dann ist die cpu dicht cock crash mehrfach mehrfach starten also
mehr mehr als ein task geht nicht und das liegt daran habe ich gerade vergessen was
ich sagen wollte task mehr als einfach excellent mitten im satz vergessen was ich sagen wollte
was auch immer zumindest geht das mit mehreren sachen nicht also mehr als eine mehr als eine
genau ja klar weil das hier einen cpu kern komplett dicht macht timo gel das kann sehr
gut sein ja ich glaube du hast recht das heißt der müsste während er sich die referenz
hier kopiert müsste der unglücklicherweise gerade dort reinkommen während der das geändert
wird das kann das kann sogar sein dass das in dieser implementierung ist keine ahnung
aber es ist zumindest anfällig für für irgendwelche probleme übrigens kill kill all so aber das
ist trotzdem eine ziemlich doofe lösung weil das macht meinen cpu kern komplett voll aber
ich habe eine andere idee was wir machen können wir machen uns ein standard set oder so ne
was mal standard q standard was ich vector hello vector task handle so tasks und da speichern
wir jetzt drinnen da speichern wir jetzt die den jeweiligen task also die referenz auf
den jeweiligen task drinnen und dann sagen wir hier unten diesem task bescheid wenn es
neue messages gibt ich kann auch kein c++ 20 verwenden ich würde kein c++ 20 verwenden
da sind paar ganz gute sachen mit dabei moment moment leute ich muss mich ich muss mich korrigieren
da sind ein paar sachen dabei die c++ nicht mehr ganz so schlecht aussehen lassen gute
sachen ich glaube es geht los hast du deine neue steckdosenleiste letztens mal noch geflasht
bekommen ne und ich habe die mittlerweile auch zurückgeschickt weil da die falsche cpu drin
ist die kann man nicht flaschen leider wie ist moment ich brauche mal das passende emote
wie ist denn das dieses ich hab doch so ein pepe pepe emote wo er auf dem klo sitzt hier
das da pepo poo ich muss nämlich mal aufs klo und ich mach dafür das passende gif transparent
und jetzt halb gif excellent save hallo speichern firefox hängt beim speichern auf dem desktop
ich glaube es sind zu viele icons auf dem desktop das macht da nicht mit
das gif wird ein bisschen schnell abgespielt das gif hat ein paar probleme gerade so jetzt
könnt ihr euch den wahnsinns joke angucken ich gehe mal kurz aufs klo ich bin gleich
wieder da aufs klo
so
So, wieder am Start.
Die wichtigste Frage zu beantworten, ja ich habe ein Tablet auf dem Klo.
Theoretisch muss jeder Raum Twitch-fähig sein.
Oh, ist es gecrasht?
Warum ist das gecrasht?
Bei was ist es gecrasht gerade?
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Oder ist das noch von vorhin?
Ich glaube das ist noch von vorhin.
Schon Linus Testchips Videos gesehen, wie Linus einen PC in seinem Bad eingebaut hat.
Nee, wenn ihr Link schickt, können wir das gleich nochmal gucken.
Achso, wisst ihr warum nur no root to host?
Weil ich ein Kacknoob bin und auch nicht eingestellt habe, dass der sich wieder verbindet wenn
er abkackt.
Na gut.
Aber ich flash jetzt eh neu.
So, jetzt müssen wir eine wichtige Sache noch machen.
Wir müssen das jetzt mal ordentlich machen.
Und zwar, das Problem ist ja, dass das ein CPU-Kern blockiert.
Deswegen werden wir das folgendermaßen machen.
Wenn dieser Task hier gestartet wird auf Logs, dann sendet er erstmal eine Antwort meinetwegen
und dann geht er in Tasks, push und edit sein eigenes Task Handle in den Vektor hier oben.
So, und dann kann ich hier unten sagen, dass wir jetzt einmal komplett einmal durch diesen
Vektor, den ich wie Task genannt habe glaube ich, durchgehen und jedem Task Bescheid sagen,
er soll doch mal sich refreschen, also er soll doch mal anfangen zu laufen und in der Zwischenzeit
soll er blocken.
So, gif, irgendwas mit gif war das, was task gif, genau, task, so, also der kopiert eine
neue Log-Message hin und sagt an jedem Task Bescheid, er soll jetzt mal Logs schicken
und solange der Task nicht Bescheid gesagt bekommt, blockt er und verbraucht keine CPU
Zeit.
Also das ging folgendermaßen, da muss man irgendwie sagen, task, take, true und ticks
to wait, irgendwas mit port, delay, also sprich, das ist jetzt zwar eine Endlosschleife, aber
der blockt an der Stelle, bis der hier unten ihm Bescheid sagt, dass er entblocken kann
und solange task geblockt ist, das ist keine Endloss-Block, sondern der braucht, er kriegt
dann keine CPU Zeit mehr, das heißt, wir können jetzt mehr als drei Verbindungen gleichzeitig
machen und lassen nicht den kompletten Controller mit Idle Loops aus, ne, das ist kein Mutex
für Arme, das ist eigentlich so, wie man es macht, das ist das, was das unterliegende
Mini-Betriebssystem mitbringt.
Das ist keine C++ Geschichte, das ist das, was das ESP32 SDK quasi mitbringt.
So, ähm, gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert, naja, exellent.
Ja, das funktioniert erstaunlich gut, ich bin mir nicht sicher, warum das so gut funktioniert.
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, warum das so gut klappt.
Warum funktioniert das so gut, ah, ha ha ha, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, es dauert
einfach nur eine Weile, dann crashs wieder, exellent, ähm, ok, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
wir geben mal den Heapspace aus, wenn wir nachher jetzt pushen, wir pushen jetzt zwei
Knobs, Heapspace, Heapspace, Free Heapspace, also wie viel RAM frei ist, ja, ist ja gut.
So, dann sehen wir jetzt nämlich, ob das Ding out of RAM läuft oder wir wirklich Multithreading-Probleme
haben.
Ich stippe ja auf Multithreading-Probleme, weil mich eh schon die ganze Zeit wundert,
warum das funktioniert.
Übrigens, weil ich gerade im Chat, weil ich gerade gesagt habe, der Chat diskutiert mal
wieder über mein Klo.
Erinnert euch dran, es ist auch nicht ungefährlich, so ein Klo zu haben, ähm, der Hersteller hat
mich benachrichtigt, dass mein Klo anfangen kann, Feuer zu fangen, vor einem Jahr oder
so.
Mittlerweile ist das gefixt, aber die haben an alle Kunden eine Nachricht geschickt, Achtung,
ihr Klo kann anfangen zu brennen.
Weil, klingt erstmal abwegig, ja, aber dort ist ja so eine Düsenreinigungsflüssigkeit
drinne und die ist wohl ausgelaufen und die konnte, wenn sie in die Elektronik läuft,
potentiell entflammt werden und hätte dann das Haus abgefackelt.
Ähm, das geht jetzt so schnell, ich sehe gar nichts, den Counter lassen wir mal weg.
Äh, was ist eigentlich, wenn die Wasserdüse kaputt geht, hast du Ersatz-Klopapier, ich
brauche trotzdem Klopapier, obwohl das mit Düse, also anscheinend interessiert es euch
ja ganz besonders genau, ich verwende die Wasserdüse vom Klo und dann putze ich nochmal
Klopapier drüber, ich benutze nicht den Föhn, das dauert mir zu lang, der Föhn, der Föhn
im Klo, da musste ja noch, da musste ja noch eine halbe Minute drauf sitzen bleiben, bis
der trocken geföhnet hat, äh, das benutze ich nicht, ganz schön wenig Speicher, komm
mal hier, aber es liegt nicht daran, dass ihm der Ram ausgeht, also Ram hat er genug,
du hast eine Popo-Dusche ja, übrigens das Video, was ich zu meinem Klo gemacht hat,
hat, äh, irgendein russischer, äh, Klo-Channel hochgeladen mit seinem eigenen Wasserzeichen
drauf, also ich hab hier ein Video gemacht zum Klo und dieses Video hat ein russischer
Channel genommen und hat, äh, sein eigenes Logo drüber gemacht und hochgeladen, ich
weiß nicht ob ich den Link noch hab, ich habs letztens im Stream schonmal gezeigt,
ich muss mal gucken, ob ich den Link noch hab, äh, ja hab ich hier geguckt, Kacomodads,
be death, be death 24, hat einfach mal ein Video geklaut und sein eigenes Logo drüber
gemacht, Funktionen, äh, wir fangen mal vielleicht bei der einfachsten Sache an,
ich meine Deckel an Absenkautomaten, ich weiß, das werden schon die Klo-Videos geklaut,
der Twitch-Channel zugeschlagen, Strike den weg, könnte ich machen, aber ehrlich gesagt
juckt es mich nicht, was ist das für ein Video Sepharo, lul, das kenne ich ja noch
gar nicht, Max FPS Revealed im Klo, oh nein, oh, Max leaked, Idiot, schläg.
Die Leute haben echt zuviel Zeile.
Was ist Linus Tech-Tips-Videos zum Klo, das gucken wir bevor wir aufgehen, bevor wir aufgehen
gucken wir uns das an, zu seinem Klo, dann weiß ich ob ich aufrüsten muss oder nicht,
oh Leute, es ist wieder gecrasht, guck mal, es ist wieder gecrasht, oder, keck wait, nee,
es ist nicht gecrasht, aber es hängt, ah, die WLAN-Verbindung ist abgeschissen, kann
das sein, ich glaube, WLAN-Verbindung ist abgekackt, top, Max, kurzer Moment, was, hast du den Snagger
gesehen, was, ach ja, den habe ich gesehen, stimmt, das ist eigentlich richtig cooles
Produkt, was der Sebaro da ausgebuddelt hat, guck mal hier, Twitter, Sebaro, Moment, Sebaro,
wo ist der Tweet, habe ich da gar nicht drauf geantwortet, Schick mal, schick mal den Link,
ich fand das echt gut, und wisst ihr was Big Brain Sache wäre, die müssen mich unbedingt
sponsoren, Sebaro, du hast recht, das Produkt ist Poggers und ich muss die anschreiben,
die sollen mich sponsoren, dann setze ich mich immer in Stream und futtere mit Ansage Snagger,
hier, der Snagger, das braucht man, Moment, Nüsse und Smarties,
jetzt bestellen, nein, nein, erst bestellen, wenn ich Reflinks habe, Leute, erst bestellen,
wenn ich Reflinks habe, nicht jetzt, erst wenn ich Reflinks habe, ich schreibe die
echt an, ihr wisst, wenn ich sowas sage, mache ich es wahrscheinlich nie, ne, ich brauche
keine Facecam dafür, ich kann sagen, so aus Snagger-Time oder irgendwas, das klingt übel,
Facecam, ich kann einfach hier, einfach Snagger in den Mittelpunkt, ich Snagger jetzt, Snagger,
das geht schon, exzellent, ne, doch, das ist gut, das gefällt mir, exquisite, so, warum
hat er jetzt no route to host, achso, weil ich nicht checke, ob wer dann abgekackt ist,
du bist langsam, was heißt langsam, ich bin 1984 geboren, okay, okay, wir müssen mal eine
Sache machen, wir müssen gucken, wenn WLAN abkackt, wenn WLAN abkackt, müssen wir reconnecten,
in 10 Jahren ist vorbei, Patrick, dann ist, dann ist durch, wir müssen erstmal nochmal
sicherstellen, dass wenn WLAN abkackt, machen wir das jetzt am besten, wenn WLAN abkackt,
neu connecten, task, task, run, muss ich irgendwie sicherstellen, dass WLAN abbleibt, wenn es
mal zwischendrin abscheißt, wer hat sich eigentlich diese komische Lambda-Syntax ausgedacht,
einfach mal alle Sonder-, alle Klammern, die es gibt, hintereinander, so, run, so, das
ganz jetzt, while, true, true, so, excellent, so, und nur disconnect is connected, not connected
okay, so, das ist das Einfachste, wir machen jetzt ein extra Task, auf der er einfach guckt,
ob das WLAN abgekackt ist, und wenn das WLAN abgekackt ist, dann startet er das WLAN,
neu, so, und jetzt noch delay alle 5, alle 5 Sekunden, so, excellent, so, machen wir
das, jetzt sollte das WLAN nicht mal abkacken, kennst du eine PCI Express SFP Plus Karte,
ich hab davon ein paar, ich hab davon ein paar, funktioniert wunderbar und kostet nicht
so viel, kriegst du viel billiger als das hier, muss man ein bisschen durchscrollen,
du kannst irgendwas nehmen, ist egal, gucken, dass der Anschluss passt, also der da nicht,
das ist QSFP Plus, dann ist gut, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was der Unterschied
ist zwischen den bisschen älteren und den neueren, wahrscheinlich, oh, ich hab keine
IP gekriegt, warum das denn, das funktioniert nicht, was ich hier gebaut habe, warum funktioniert
das nicht, was ich hier gebaut habe, ah, weil das Delay da nachläuft, lull, ok, das ist
nicht schön, aber ich hab jetzt keinen Bock, das ordentlich zu bauen, gut ist, vielleicht
nur, dass das WLAN immer abbleibt, bis denn Sebaro, ja, also Leute, wir machen auch nur
noch eine halbe Stunde, ne, eine halbe Stunde oder so, aber wir machen jetzt noch eine wichtige
Sache, die machen wir jetzt noch, nämlich gucken, dass das mit den Logs funktioniert,
das Emote ist nice, ja, ich hab übrigens noch jede Menge Emote-Slots auf FFZ und bei
TwitchTV, genau, Linus Test-Tipps-Videos gucken wir an, so, Memory failed, Memory failed,
warum ist es jetzt Memory failed, eben gingen noch noch drei Verbindungen, CacWade, eben
gingen nur noch drei Verbindungen, warum gehen jetzt nur zwei Verbindungen, was ist da los,
ah, ich weiß warum, wahrscheinlich braucht der WLAN-Task zu viel RAM, der WLAN-Task braucht
zu viel RAM, jetzt kriege ich nur zwei Verbindungen hin, oh, oh, oh, was ist jetzt los, das hat
gelaggt, ComaVilla PoE-Stream, ich hab die Season noch nicht gespielt, wahrscheinlich
erstmal nicht, ne, ist nicht genug RAM da für eine dritte Verbindung, RIP, ich glaube,
es macht auch keinen Sinn, die Season noch einzusteigen, oder was, wie lange läuft
denn die aktuelle Path of Exile-Season, schon, macht es denn noch Sinn einzusteigen die Season,
ich hab noch keine Zeit mich damit zu beschäftigen, Path of Exile ist immer so ein Ding, wo du
übelst Theorie craften musst, vielleicht, okay, dann vielleicht mache ich mir doch noch
einen Char, das verbraucht zu viel RAM, ja gut, SSL-Connection sind halt, man könnte
noch gucken, man könnte das Customizable machen, dass man hier sagt, ey, keine Ahnung, Max-Task
oder so, man macht standardmäßig jetzt gleich drei, und man könnte das übergeben, irgendwie
so, dann könnte man das auch limitieren auf eins oder zwei, oder, mal gucken eigentlich,
ja, so, aber wir müssen das jetzt noch fixen, weil das kackt ab und zu ab, wobei, kackt
das überhaupt noch ab, jetzt wo wir das mit dem Task Notify gemacht haben, wahrscheinlich
kackt das jetzt gar nicht mehr ab, scheint ja relativ stable zu sein gerade, ähm, übrigens
warum zeigt das kein Ayaya mehr an, was ist hier, Moment, Draw, Jaja, ich hab wirklich
vergessen Ayaya Get Time, das ist ja absolut indiskutabel, dass der kein Ayaya mehr malt
auf das Display, wie gehts der Katz, der gehts gut, die war eben hier und dann hat sie sich
wieder verpisst, so, jetzt sollte es, wie sich das gehört, wieder Ayaya malen aufs Display
und nicht einfach, einfach so ein komisches, iii, das ist ja langweilig, so ein, und, ah,
Ayaya, jetzt funktioniert es wieder, sehr gut, ups, sehr schön, ähm, also, was wir
machen könnten, ist mal schauen, das Display auszumachen, und ich werd mal das Display
kurz ausschalten, äh, Display, Display, hier, mach das Display mal kurz aus, dann haben
wir nämlich ein bisschen mehr RAM, und mit mehr RAM können wir dann noch ein paar Verbindungen
mehr aufmachen, und dann können wir gucken, ob, ob das jetzt aus irgendwelchen magischen
Gründen, äh, nicht crasht, wenn wir das so gebaut haben, mich würd's immer noch ein
bisschen wundern, also mich wundert's immer noch ein bisschen, warum das funktioniert,
ehrlich gesagt, aber ich will mich jetzt ja mal nicht beschweren, dass das funktioniert,
also normalerweise hätte ich zumindest gesagt, dass man hier noch irgendeinen Mutext drum
rum machen muss, was, BitConnect, warum, aber wenn es jetzt sein muss, dann auch BitConnect,
guck, jetzt haben wir mehr RAM, jetzt können wir noch ein paar Verbindungen mehr aufbauen,
jetzt würden wir sogar bis zu vier Connections hinkriegen, also aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ist das halbwegs ThreadSafe, und ich versteh nicht warum, aber ok, dann müssen wir nix
locken, dann geht's halt einfach so, auch in Ordnung, ich reiß mich da jetzt ja nicht
rum, dass man das komplizierter machen muss als nötig, aber warum ist ThreadSafe, versteh
ich immer noch nicht, so, wir machen das mal eins hoch, wir gucken mal, wie es mit vier
Verbindungen ist, mit vier Tests, komm, wir machen mal bis auf fünf maximale Tests hoch,
wir gucken, wie viele wir durchkriegen, wie viele Verbindungen maximal gehen, ok, so,
erste Verbindung, pass, zweite, dritte, vier Verbindungen, vier, ok, ob noch eine geht,
fünf, PulseChamp, PulseChamp, oh, also, ich mein, man merkt schon, dass es ein bisschen
laggt, langsam, oh, ich glaub, das war's, oh, es hat rebooted, oh, oh, oh, RIP, nee,
das WLAN hat sich neu gestartet, das WLAN hat sich neu gestartet, das WLAN hat sich
neu gestartet und dabei ist er abgekackt, ok, diesen Fall hab ich nicht bedacht, dass
das WLAN ja weg sein könnte, also sprich, ich müsste irgendwie noch mitbekommen, wenn
das WLAN weggeht und da müsste ich alle Verbindungen abbauen oder, oder, oder löschen, ok, also
mal hier, wir können ja mal, wir können ja mal von Hand das ausprobieren, nutzt du
einen T-MAX Befehl, nee, ich verwende, das ist AIMA Curl, achso, ich mach halt, ich mach
halt ein Panel auf, ne, für das, für T-MAX, ja, das ist mit T-MAX, einfach ein Split,
so, ok, das probieren wir nochmal, nochmal eine Sache aus, fuck, jetzt hab ich vergessen,
was ich machen wollte, genau, ich wollte alle, alle paar Sekunden einfach WLAN disconnecten,
einfach alle paar Sekunden WLAN disconnecten, um gut ist, ich hab mir doch so, ich hab mir
doch irgendeinen, irgendeinen, so einen Timer gebaut, MS, so, alle, ich lass einfach alle,
alle, keine Ahnung, alle 10 Sekunden, lass ich das WLAN disconnecten und, ähm, dann
schauen wir mal, wie der das handelt, wahrscheinlich gar nicht, wahrscheinlich gar nicht, so und
hier schreiben wir jetzt hin, äh, is not connected, keine Ahnung, WiFi failed, nee,
reconnect, so, irgendwas, ich brauch einfach, ich brauch einfach ne, ne, ne Message, dass
ich was erkenne, äh, ja, das geht auch, du kannst, ähm, das geht, du kannst, ähm,
was da machen, synchronize, synchronize panes, äh, nee, äh, synchronize, äh, on, nee,
synchron, oh, was ist denn T-Mark, synchronize panes 1, okay, ich hab's vergessen, wie das
geht, irgendwie so, synchronize panes, ja, ich weiß, ich kenn die Option dafür nicht,
dann kannst du in allen gleichzeitig schreiben, on, ach, set we, synchronize panes, okay,
T-Mark settings, also, man kann, man kann sowas hier machen, ups, hallo, man kann sowas
hier machen, on, und jetzt schreib ich, guck, jetzt schreib ich in jedem gleichzeitig, set
we durch keqwe ersetzen, okay, die Verbindungen hängen, oh, oh, oh, die Verbindungen hängen,
wenn sich WLAN neu startet, das, äh, mag der irgendwie nicht, also, da hat er was,
da hat er was dagegen, also, da hat er was dagegen, wenn, wenn WLAN an- und ausgeschaltet
ist, mag er nicht, das mag er nicht, da hat er irgendwelche Schmerzen mit, oh, oh, oh,
Wifi is not resetted, okay, also, da hat er auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Schmerzen mit,
das, das mag er nicht so, wenn sich das WLAN resettet zwischendurch, ich mein, hier kann
man ja allzu viel verkehrt machen, solang, ähm, warte mal, wo hab ich das Delay, eigentlich,
so, ohne, ohne Traffic is kein Problem, connected, so, alle 10 Sekunden disconnect, reconnect,
er sollte jetzt nicht die IP ausgeben, sollte jetzt nicht eigentlich die IP ausgeben, ach,
ne, das reconnecten funktioniert nicht, ach, ne, die IP geb ich hier aus, irgendwo, ne,
die IP geb ich nur hier aus, okay, hab irgendeinen Mist eingetragen, ha, also, das reconnecten
ohne Traffic funktioniert, ähm, doch, aber das Auto reconnect, das geht, aber es funktioniert
bei mir nicht richtig, ich hab das schon ein paar mal probiert und der vergisst das trotzdem
zwischendurch, ich muss immer manuell checken, also, das Auto reconnect ist irgendwie ein
bisschen, ein bisschen unzuverlässig, so, Wi-Fi reconnect, connect, okay, so, und wenn,
wenn ne Verbindung läuft und das WLAN abkackt, dann macht er Probleme, ja, okay, RIP, das
mag er nicht, das mag er nicht, wenn ihm die WLAN Verbindung unterm Arsch wegfliegt, okay,
das muss ich noch irgendwie handeln, da muss man irgendwie mitbekommen, wenn WLAN wegfliegt
und die Verbindung abbauen, weil der hat, der hat irgendwelche Schmerzen damit, wenn
ihm das, wenn ihm die WLAN Verbindung wegfliegt, aber das guck ich mir nicht heute an, das
ist mir zu big brain, aber an sich funktioniert es hier mit reconnecten automatisch, ich glaube,
ich weiß woran das liegt, der bleibt hier bestimmt hängen, man die Tasks sind wahrscheinlich
nicht fertig, der bleibt, der bleibt hier bestimmt irgendwo, irgendwo hängen bei, wenn man das
so macht, gut, was auch immer, für heute ist genug, wir gucken uns jetzt noch das Linus
Tech Tips Bart Video an, wir gucken, ob ich da upgraden muss, das ist so ein typischer
Ami-Switch irgendwie, aber wobei, das geht ja hier im Prinzip auch, wenn da passende
Sachen hinter denen, hinter den Fliesen hast, wobei die Amis haben hinter den Fliesen wahrscheinlich
Holz, das Holz, Holzhäuser haben die ja total oft, wobei Linus sich das leisten könnte
ein ordentliches Haus zu bauen, da bräuchte eigentlich gar kein Holzhaus, ah yes exquisite,
viel zu laut, von was wurde das gesponsert, von Asus, naja, warum nicht, von Asus, von
Asus, naja, warum nicht, yes my friends, who but us would be crazy enough to build a hardcore
gaming setup in a bathroom, yeah Bitwit, but we had the idea first and he also did it
wrong, I mean who sits on the throne long enough to actually play a game, you wanna play
a game, you wanna relax, you know, you wanna lounge, and you wanna hang out with Brian
the electrician, hey guys, to put some fancy new outlets on your walls, so you can set
up a sick TV, gut, das ist wie gesagt ein Ami-Häuser kein Problem, da kannst du ja einfach
Löcher in die Wand sägen, above your bathtub, let's see how this goes, the plan for today
is actually pretty straight forward, I've already got electrical wiring up in my attic
for an outlet and some lights that are up there, so what we're gonna do is we're gonna tie
into that, fish the wiring down this wall, put a plug on this wall, add some RGB and
then up this ladder, I've got a shelf right here sitting next to an outlet that we're
gonna use. Der hat, der hat ne Treppe in seinem Bad? Warum hat der ne Treppe auf dem Dachboden
in seinem Bad? Warum ist da ne Treppe? Das ist die eigentliche Frage, die ich mir jetzt
stelle. The wiring down this wall, put a plug on this wall, add some RGB and then up this
wall. X-Faitl, 15 Monate, X-Quizet Subscription, gut, danke für die Subs. I've got a shelf right
here sitting next to an outlet that we're gonna use to power our TUF RTX 3090 gaming
rig. That's right my friends, the fastest computer in my house is gonna be in my bathroom.
Every time we've put an electrical outlet in my house you've actually done literally
all the work, so I'm not sure what the first step is here. Find a stud? Well, I'll figure
out where you want to put the plug. Ah, yes, good, on the wall. One small problem though,
Brian. What's that? The insulation's in now. So we're gonna need to diggy diggy hole. Okay.
I can give you a sharper bit, I've got lots of tools. Just like you have lots of screws?
One of them are loose. That is wood. Ah, that's a problem. You can see the brace. Ah, ex-excellent
endoskop. Why would they have extra bracing on an interior wall like that? It might partly
be like I say, because the plumbing stack's here, so to help brace that. Relax, 10 Monate,
so we can try a different wall cavity. Alright, let's do that. Sounds good. Wohnt er nicht in
Kanada? Doch, das kann sein, aber da sind anscheinend die Häuser auch aus Holz. Wobei, in Kanada
ist er nicht kalt, da sollte man die Häuser eigentlich ordentlich bauen. RTX 3080 are
that it's factory overclocked and boosts up to 1850 MHz. First of all, easy sellout. That's
been newly tuned with a very great caps and other tough components to enhance durability.
Was ist tough? Ich kenne von Asus plus Rock und das normale Asus Zeug. Was ist denn jetzt
schon wieder tough? Die haben auch wirklich laufend einen neuen Greppel, der im Prinzip
das alte in neuer Farbe ist. Oh, jetzt komm ich mir mit meinem Tablet auf dem Klo aber
minderwertig vorher. Da wird's mal Zeit abzukraten, würde ich sagen. So ein kleiner LCD Fernseh
im Klo muss schon sein. Warum braucht er denn ein Gaming System im Bad? Also ich meine,
ein für Fernseh und sonst was, da wird's ja auch was deutlich leistungsärmeres tun.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir auch warum er das Video gemacht hat, um die Grafikkarte zu verbauen.
Mach mal kurz ein bisschen leiser, da schreit sie rum heute. Okay, muss, muss. Ich mein,
wenn er es hat, warum nicht? Okay, das dürfte mir so ein typisches Influencer Promotion
Package sein. Nicht dass es großartig was bringen würde. Das haben die 100 Pro mit ihm
ausgemacht, dass er sowas sagt im Video. So nach dem Motto, es ist nicht total unsinnig
so ultraschnellen RAM zu kaufen. Nee, nee, weil ultraschneller RAM ist ja auch nicht
nur schnell, sondern ultraschneller RAM ist auch haltbar. Ultraschneller RAM, also so richtig
übertrieben schneller RAM ist halt einfach sinnlos Fenster zum äh äh nicht sinnlos
Fenster zum Geld rausgeschmissen, sinnlos Geld zum Fenster rausgeschmissen.
Außer man ist der Bauer und möchte dann alles übertacken oder am besten noch mit Flüssigstickstoff.
Würdest du nicht auch sowas sagen, wenn du dir dafür einen Rechner ins Bad stellen könntest?
Nö, weil ich da überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck für habe und ich wette mit dir, der bekommt
da auch noch was für. Der kann sich nicht einfach den Rechner ins Bad stellen. Also
ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn dich so ein Channel erwähnt nur, dass das schonmal äh
vierstellig äh fünfstellig ist. Ich mein, das ist zur Hälfte einfach nur Promotion
das Ding. Wie, er muss, er muss selbst dran ziehen. Er muss selbst am Fernseher ziehen,
ich dachte, der Fernseher kommt natürlich automatisch runtergelaufen.
Ist Anker nicht das China Zeug oder verwechsel ich das gerade?
Genau, nicht mal, nicht mal motorisiert, was ist das denn?
Und dann spritzt er erstmal schön Shampong dran.
Also ist das funktioniert aber wirklich recht gut?
Ich glaube langsam, dass die solche Sachen ähm absichtlich einbauen, weil fast jedes
Video ist dann zufälligerweise ein Kabel zu kurz und auf den letzten Drücker klickt
man es dann doch hin, dass es funktioniert. Ja aber ganz runterziehen kann er es nicht
mehr oder?
Moment, man kann seine Smart Beleuchtung jetzt mit Fortnite synchronisieren lassen?
Ja.
Wie viel bezahlt ich für das?
Es ist ein Dimmer
Ich weiß nicht, es gibt viel Elektronik
Über meinem Bathtub
Ist das der Masterplan, um mich endlich auszuweichen, Leute?
Ich muss nur diese Kabelkabeln machen
Und wir sind rein?
In Bezug auf die Peripheral
Ich werde den Dongle für den RG Strix
2.4
Also es ist 2.4 GHz für Low Latency
So geil, das ist einfach ein komplettes Video
Immer wieder zwischendurch
Windows
Na gut, wenn er spielen will, was sonst?
Das ist komplett überflüssig
Das ist auch kaputt nach einem Baden
Wenn du nicht aufpasst, schmeißt du die Tastatur ins Wasser
Video hier
Wow, das ist cool
Ich kann hier rein
130 FPS
Doom Eternal 4K
Vor allem, du kannst die Maus doch kaum bewegen
Und im Zweifelsfall, da würde ich im Zweifelsfall sogar lieber einen Xbox Controller für nehmen
Aber gut, jeder wie er will
Jetzt bewegst du dich falsch und schon legt das Ding im Wasser
Ja gut, eigentlich ganz gut, aber zum größten Teil ziemlich überflüssig
Tja
Meine Control-Taste ist wieder abgefallen
Na gut, das war's für heute
Okay Leute, machen wir vielleicht morgen weiter
Das war zu big brain, das noch zu fixen mit dem WLAN
Was, jetzt zeigen die nicht mal den Monitor?
Ah, ich hab's schon zugemacht
Was, der Controller ist ins Wasser gefallen? Echt?
Nee, der Controller ist doch noch da
Ach so, meinste
Stimmt, der Controller ist ins Wasser gefallen
Okay, dann machen wir mal weiter
Ach so, meinste, stimmt, der Controller ist ins Wasser gefallen
Deswegen zeigen sie es nicht mehr unten
Sehr gute Idee, ja, exellent
Also Leute, wir sehen uns dann morgen oder so, mal schauen
Bis dann, macht's gut, CU
Ach nee, doch nicht CU, ich hoste den M-Core
Ich hoste den M-Core
Host, M-Core, nee Raid, wir raiden den M-Core
Hab ich grad gesehen, dass der M-Corn gekommen ist
Wir raiden den M-Core, exellent
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns, macht's gut, bis dann, CU